Good morning. Seeing that the board members are present, Brooks, can you please call the
roll?
Good morning. Member Bonanca.
Here.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Escobedo.
Here.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Lewis.
Here.
Member McQuillan.
Member Olken.
Here.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
We have a quorum.
Wonderful. I hereby call the July 2022 meeting of the State Board of Education to order at
8.33 a.m. and I'd like to commence by saluting the flag. Member Bonanca, could you please
lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Absolutely. Please stand for the pledge.
Ready? Salute. I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all. Thank you.
Thank you.
And with that, I'm going to frame us up with some general announcements. The proposed waiver
consent items are W1 through W19. The proposed regular consent items are items 6 through
14. There are two public hearings on the agenda. Item 5 is the proposed formation of a new
unified school district from the Northgate portion of the Mount Diablo Unified School
District in Contra Costa County. Item 17 is the appeal of the denial of a petition for
the establishment of a classroom-based charter school pursuant to California Education Code
Section 47605K2. Consideration of the allegations of abuse of discretion made by Samoa Beach
Academy, which was denied by the Northern Humboldt Union High School District and the
Humboldt County Board of Education. We have some changes in the agenda. We will reopen
item 1, SBE priorities, later this afternoon to take action on the May 2022 minutes and
take up state board liaison reports. In terms of public input, members of the public wishing
to call in for public comment should view the livestream of the meeting to know what
time public comment will occur for each item. Public comment may be provided by dialing
the phone number, entering a participant access code, and then following each of their
operator's prompts. Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue. The operator
will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment. We'll also ask
callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they are following the
live webcast to avoid an echoing effect. Public comment will be limited to one minute for
each speaker. Item 15 is the general public comment item during which members of the public
may provide comment on matters that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones when not speaking and keep your cameras on
at all times except during the scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout
today's virtual meeting. If you do need to take a modest break, please feel free to do so,
but keep with us every time that you can. For each item on the agenda, there will be an
opportunity for the board members to raise their Zoom hand if they would like to ask a question
or make a comment. That's in the participant reactions that I will be watching for your hands.
Item one is our state board projects and priorities item. I'll now turn it over to State
Superintendent Tony Thurman to provide his report. Superintendent.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. Good morning to you, to the members of the board, to our
students, our educators, our families, and all who are participating in today's meeting. As we
are in summer school and in the summer, I want to extend best wishes to all of our students and
families. I also want to start by acknowledging our first responders and firefighters who are
working across the state to contain many of the fires that we have seen in recent days and thank
also our emergency response team that continues to work with our first responders in ways to
support our school communities when they're impacted by our fires. Also want to provide
acknowledgement and a shout out to all of our teachers and educators and administrators and
others who are working in summer school, providing opportunities for credit recovery, learning
recovery, expanded learning, recognizing the hard work that continues to take place in the incredible
opportunity that summer provides, but the fact that many are still working and want to acknowledge
them and thank them. I do want to provide you some highlights that since we last met, the
legislature and the governor have finalized a budget. There are some incredible highlights for
California education. As we reach this inflection point of building and better and building back
from what the pandemic has created, our schools have tremendous opportunities to ensure that our
students can recover, that they can heal, and that they can thrive moving forward. Not the least of
which is an increase to the LCFF base by about $9 billion. This is a 13% increase in funding for
our schools. They are receiving a cost of living adjustment. That's more than 6%. When you think
about all these measures, including an $8 billion block grant that schools will be receiving for
discretionary purposes to support literacy and expanded learning and other programs, it means that
California schools are nearing being 10th in the nation in per pupil spending. Significant change
for us considering just a few years California was near 50th. Our schools have incredible
resources that they can use going forward to help our students heal and thrive. Just a few
highlights of this, recognizing that students need more supports in counseling. Tremendous
resources made available in this budget. You all know that we sponsored SB 1229 in our call to
help us attract 10,000 new mental health clinicians to the field. We're grateful that the
budget creates a pathway to provide $20,000 scholarships to anyone who will become a mental
health clinician in a high needs community and that that money continues to be available for
teachers and educators in addition to $250 million in residency programs to support them. I want to
thank a lot of folks who have helped to make these things happen, including our state board president,
Dr. Jarling Hammond, the governor, the legislature. You will see incredible resources like $250 million
for literacy coaches and specialists to support students in schools of high need. Some $500 million
for career technical education for those who want to learn and get on pathways in technology, health,
education. Another $200 million to support our expansion of dual language immersion programs.
$3 billion for expanded learning programs. Continuing to build on our universal meals programs,
another $596 million to support universal meals. That means that there will be reimbursement rates to
support our schools. There's another $600 million to help our schools build out their kitchens and
their infrastructure so we can provide more healthy meals for our students throughout the state.
$10 million for books and $15 million for professional development for our educators
related to literacy. Another $1 billion for community schools. Again, I want to thank this board
and for your incredible work to help us as we move forward. Thank you.
And for your incredible work to help us as we rolled out the first round
of community schools funding part of a $3 billion initiative and the recognition of the legislature
and the governor that we need to continue to provide community schools. So another $10 million
to build on the anti-bias grants that are currently being provided.
What does this all mean? In spite of big challenges that our schools have faced over the last two years,
the resiliency that our students and parents and educators have shown, California schools have the resources
to help transform public education. As you can see here, California is leading the way with being able
to provide universal meals for every hungry student regardless of their background.
I want to thank the board and for your incredible work to help us as we rolled out the first round of
community schools funding part of a $10 million initiative and the recognition of the legislature
and the governor that we need to provide community schools, universal preschool, and our state
community schools for professional development, a robust mental health program.
So these are just a few of the highlights.
Thank you very much for participating. Madam President, I would just like to leave you with this
and let you know that there are two new division directors that will be presenting before this body from time to time.
One, a very familiar face who will be taking over, has officially taken over
of the educator excellence and equity division. That's Monique McWane who's been serving in the division
who has served 11 years at CDE. We're grateful for her leadership.
Many of you know her as someone who's helped to roll out the educator effectiveness grant
billions to support professional development for educators on every topic that you can imagine
from closing the opportunity gap to how we address bias in schools.
We're grateful and excited to continue to work with Monique in this role and to announce
a new director of the student achievement and support division.
You will see Will McGee who has most recently served as the director of the
Office of African American Male Achievement and will continue to lead the efforts of our
student achievement and support division. Will has more than 25 years of
experience in public education. He's a former school board member and another great addition to our team
of division directors and so we look forward to when they'll be presenting before you. As always, I'm happy to submit
any questions that the members of the board may have. This concludes my report.
Thank you very much. Lots of good news to report there.
I'll start my report by congratulating all of the educators, parents, and students across the state
for the tremendous work they devoted to learning through another challenging year.
As the pandemic has evolved into an endemic and we've had to adjust to changing circumstances on a regular basis,
so many schools have done wonderful work in learning recovery. Many of them are still in session for summer
programming in that regard, supports for social and emotional welfare, and rebuilding community.
We appreciate you, all who are engaged in that difficult work.
I want to give a special shout out to the graduates, our seniors, whose high school
experience was really shaped by COVID and who persevered through all of that, but also
I want to congratulate the eighth graders who have graduated, the fifth or sixth graders who stepped up to middle school,
even the preschoolers who are stepping off to kindergarten.
I was reminded of the significance of graduation when I attended my son's very long
graduation ceremony from University of California at Berkeley for his doctoral program.
As I was helping to try to keep my grandson, Kofi, engaged, he's three years old,
he kept asking, what is graduation? What is graduation? I tried lots of different definitions,
but being told that his father, it meant that his father would no longer have to go to school
made him happy for a moment, but then when he realized that he too could graduate and would not be
going to school someday, he was very sad about that. So graduation is a mixed bag,
but there are millions of students who feel in California happy to be in school,
and we are working towards the day when that is true for every single student in the state.
The superintendent gave a wonderful report about the giant steps forward
that we've had in support of our public schools this year with huge investments in local control funding formula,
which over the last three years has been a 30% increase.
We were well below the national average in spending on schools for many, many, many years.
We are now finally above the national average and making progress towards a real
whole child, whole school, whole community, whole state approach to education.
You heard all of the details around that just a moment ago.
I think that part of that message, as one of the reporters noted when the budget was announced,
this is a once in a generation budget. We are trying to meet our students where they are
and transform our schools through a student-centered lens, and we're working to rebuild and strengthen
relationships between educators, students, and families, relationships that are at the heart of our work.
This work is actually redefining education in this state and setting a national example
of what a 21st century equity-informed system could look like.
Indeed, today, Governor Newsom will accept an award on behalf of all of us for the
Innovation in Education in the State from the Education Commission of the States,
the Frank Newman Award. It's kind of like an Oscars for Education Policy with less of the drama,
I presume. We'll hear more later. And in announcing the award, ECS said that
California is, quote, demonstrating an intentional comprehensive investment of funding and other resources
that recognize and honor whole child approaches to education, not only instruction.
ECS pointed to our local control funding formula as one of the nation's most equitable formulas.
They also called out the additional funding provided schools over the last three years for more teachers,
counselors, paraprofessionals, our large investment to scale summer school, before and after
school programming, our community school partnership program. And, of course,
it does take a village to innovate and implement, so the Newman Award really recognizes
everyone in our system who is doing this work. And speaking of the hard work that has been
underway in the state, I want to congratulate the staffs of our state board, our Department of Education,
our Commission on Teacher Credentialing, who have worked together so hard to provide our communities with
meaningful data about teacher assignments in California. You may know that the teacher assignment
monitoring data was posted last week. It got quite a few newspaper articles across the state.
It actually required linking databases across agencies, undertaking a Herculean task,
identifying every course or class being taught in the schools, then matching it to teacher credentialing
information for every one of our 5.9 million students, and then sending all that information
to the local level for investigation, corrections, and revising the data set in the response to that.
And the results show that statewide, the large majority of courses and classes are taught by teachers
who are fully certified for the content and the students they teach, about 83 percent.
Among the remainder are teachers who are teaching out of field, still in training,
or on various kinds of temporary or emergency permits.
And the numbers of such teachers are much, much higher in low income schools.
So there's an equity mission and agenda that accompanies the release of those statistics.
Those statistics will soon find an annual home in the state data system.
They are a useful benchmark. They flag that there is much work to be done.
to address the long-term teacher shortage, which is a national phenomenon.
We are not alone. This is something that's occurring across the country.
And it was made worse by the pandemic.
So Governor Newsom has started working on this issue as soon as he took office in 2019
with investments in teacher and leader development.
He and the legislature have been working each year to address the issue more fully.
The budget in 2021 featured, as Superintendent Thurmond noted,
$3.6 billion in multiple recruitment and retention initiatives
that were aimed at increasing and supporting the well-prepared educator workforce
by subsidizing preparations, supporting expert teachers
who could mentor and coach beginners in high-need schools.
And those programs are beginning to become more and more important.
Over the last two years, we've seen a 20% increase
in the number of people enrolled in teacher education
after years and years of sharp decrease.
And this past year, I'm told there's an even greater increase.
I haven't seen the specific numbers yet.
But we are drawing more people to the profession.
We want to bring them in in ways that are effective.
We want to bring them in in ways that are supported,
where they can receive the mentoring and
working condition supports that make it possible to do the job
well and to stay in teaching.
So we're pointed in some promising directions.
There are still challenges to come.
But with that, I look forward to the work that we will undertake
in this meeting. One of the things on our agenda is
looking at the accountability and indicator
system in California, of which these new data will be a part.
We undertook in the state to create a very
at the time, a very unusual and innovative approach
to indicators. You may recall, if you have a long
enough memory, that there was an era where the only data that was
used to identify schools and then kind of place them in
a test and punish mode were test score data
long before the federal government allowed for
multiple measures. California went there anyway
with our state priorities and with the development of the dashboard
that really looks at things that have to do with what
students are receiving in school in terms of the kind of
curriculum opportunities, the kind of resources available,
the kind of curriculum
they're enabled to pursue, the kind of climate that they
experience, as well as multiple indicators of what they
have the opportunity to accomplish, including
access to college preparatory curriculum
and high quality CTE curriculum to
literacy, to civic engagement, as well as
to evidence of academic accomplishment through
test scores, completion of rigorous courses like AP courses and
IB courses and so on. We were the first
state to really identify such an approach
to take into account growth or progress as well as
status. There's now a moment
being invited by the US Department of Education for people to think
even more deeply about how to use
indicators, evidence, data in a cycle
of continuous improvement. And we'll have a chance to undertake
some thinking about that over the coming months beginning
today. So with that, let's get to work. I
want to move to the next item on the agenda, but I had to
escape the leaf blow.
Where they were, because now
they're coming to another part of the house. So I can
get us going on the next item. So give me one
second to get myself relocated.
If I didn't have my background on, you could get a tour of my house.
Alright.
So now that we've
done our reports, I want to announce that we are going to
honor a very important member of the state board staff for
many years, Patricia Dacasse. Patricia is joining
us via Zoom. There she is. Hello, how are you?
Good to see you. Good morning, state
board president. It's great to see you. Thank you.
I want to announce that after more than 12 years
of service to the state board of education, under three different administrations,
over 30 years of state service, Patricia is retiring.
Her last day in the office was June 15th. We have a certificate
for Patricia that honors her contributions to the state board.
We have a picture of that certificate, which is in front of you now.
And it states, in recognition of outstanding service to
the state board of education, I sincerely appreciate your dedication
to the meaningful work we do on behalf of California's children
on December 15th, 2009 to June 15th,
2022. And so, of course, we'll mail the certificate
to you, Patricia. Would you like to say a few words?
Yes, thank you so much, President Darling-Hammond and
Vice President Glover Woods,
Superintendent. I just want to
say that it's been an honor and a privilege to work with each
and every one of you during the course
of the last nearly 13 years. And
you know, I learned so much from each and every one
of you. I think that we are in a much better place in California as
you know, your statement,
both the superintendent's presentation as well as your
statement this morning is a testament to how far we've come
in the past many years. And
in terms of our investments in education, it's been an honor
to work with all of you and
just to work with the staff as well as the support from the California
Department of Education. Without our strong partnership with
department staff, we would really, you know,
we all are
stronger by working together. So I just,
you know, we laid a lot of foundational work
in the last, you know, several years by developing new
standards. I was involved in the development of the ELD standards
as well as the California NGSS standards
and seeing them through, through the assessments
to strengthen the relationship between the teaching
and learning experience for students. All of this is, you know,
all of this work, you know, the history social science
framework that I worked on and, you know, just seeing all of the different assessments
get to where we are in terms of online assessments and
you know, the work that I did for workforce issues
and broadband on behalf of the administration.
You know, I feel very honored to have had the opportunity
to work with all of you and so
you know, it's time to turn a new chapter
as they say. And I know that I'm leaving the board
in a, you know, all of you in a much
we are all in a much stronger place than we were when I first arrived.
So it's been a wonderful experience. Thank you so much.
Well, we appreciate all that you've done and I know that travel is on your
agenda in some exciting ways and we wish you all
the best in this next chapter. Thank you. Thank you so much.
And with that we're going to move to item two.
Item two is the update on the implementation of the integrated local state
and federal accountability and continuous improvement system. It's a
study session for us on the development history implementation
and indicators in the accountability system. This is an item
for information only and there's no specific action
recommended at this time. I mentioned
in my president's report that there is a
an opportunity at this moment to be
thinking again about where we want to build on
the work that's been done before and continue to
think about what kinds of information in the
accountability and indicator system will help schools
get the knowledge that they need to continuously
improve to engage with the support system.
I mentioned that California was one of the first to engage in this approach
to an accountability system. And in
fact the Every Student Succeeds Act, the federal act
that we now operate under, took a page out of
California's book in authorizing multiple measures. The U.S. Department
of Education just in February put out a
statement, a guidance statement, indicating that they were open to
states going further in
looking at ways to evaluate, to
support, to report on indicators
of equity and access for students to high quality
education. There were some rules that were in place
from previous administrations that are not in the law that can be
adjusted that will open the door for
some new thinking around indicators. So we'll be having conversations
over the coming months about where California is and wants to
go in its work in this regard to support
schools, to support students in ways that allow
the system to improve. With that I'm going to
pass the ball to Cindy Kazanis. Thank you
President Darlene Hammond, Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis, Measurement
and Accountability Reporting Division. And I am
happy to be here today to talk through a couple
of things around the dashboard. This is really meant to lay the foundation for future
action the board will be taking over the next year
or more to shape our accountability system.
I am grateful for the team in putting this together. It's
not the work of one person, it's the work of many. And in fact it's many
divisions and we're really excited to have a new director of
our title one division is what we used to
call it and our acronym is SASD and I always forget
what it stands for. But really excited to have Will
here in person today to also listen to the item
and to present. So you will hear more than just my voice this
morning. You're going to hear multiple voices to help move this
presentation along. So with that
our objectives are really to give you an overview for how this system
was built and also to review what the requirements were under
the state and federal laws and President Darling-Hammond
has already given you a brief overview about the context for
the federal piece at least. We will also talk a little
bit, we'll intersperse the conversation with the board action, prior board actions
that is, around the methodology of this and such.
And then finally we do value
and we definitely respond and adjust things
when we hear public input around the system. And so this system was built
on the premise of public feedback and so you're going to hear about our continuous
improvement cycle as well. So as far as topics
again foundation, we're going to get into some broad
overviews about the state indicators, our local indicators and we're going to talk a bit about
our partner engagement and the annual review process.
So in terms of the local control funding formula
when I was in graduate school in the early 2000s
at Syracuse there were people that were working on the getting down to fact
studies and those getting down to fact studies really provided the basis in 2008
for the local control funding formula and what you see in education today.
And so I thought this quote was really a very good
way to talk about what the intentions were of this law, how to bring
government closer to the classroom where all the decisions really
are made on a daily basis. You know putting out an accountability or dashboard
once a year doesn't get into what's happening in the classroom on a daily basis.
Where accountability is happening every day with a teacher, whether the teacher's
taking attendance, they're learning about what their students are progressing
on and so I think it's really important to just lead with
that intention about how
this main fundamental change is not only to policies around accountability
but funding and transparency for education.
So in that vein we're almost going to be at
a decade celebrating this next year or at the end of
the year with the local control, the LCFF
or local control funding formula. And when I think back to 2013
and the broad support it got not only in legislature but in
our various communities
that follow education and those that didn't follow education that do
now as a result of LCFF, it really had broad-based support.
One of the things that it required, one of the big lifts was that the State Board of Education
was designated to develop a new accountability system.
And this was replacing our old accountability system which was
called the Academic Performance Index. And so
this was really revolutionary for California looking at things beyond
test scores. So we're going to talk through throughout this presentation about the emphasis
on really a whole child approach and multi-points
of information around student performance, student outcomes
and how the system is ultimately supporting specific student
groups, schools and districts.
So the purpose of LCFF was really
a three-prong approach. Looking at funding, making sure that we were distributing
funding to schools equitably, making sure that the
decisions that were made locally and the process that
is outlined through the local control funding formula that Josh will talk about
stays local. And then looking at our achievement
and measuring it broadly. So beyond again our traditional look
at student test scores.
Shifting from the state law to federal
law, nearly two years later the Every Student Succeeds
Act was signed into law by then President Barack Obama.
And I think too it's interesting to see again the intent of one of
the main individuals behind the approval
of this and who signed it into law, what they thought that the Every Student
Succeeds Act was going to do and how it was going to change education.
And so you can really see this focus on college, future careers,
building upon prior reforms, but still holding
to a high standard for teaching and learning, but also allowing states
to have a bit of independence and making, holding
states accountable for defining certain things such as
how our teachers defined under what
President Darling-Hammond just spoke about with our teacher data release. So with that in
mind, I think it's also important to point out that
there still is a focus on looking at our lowest performing schools
and also paying attention to those achievement gaps and
targeting funding accordingly.
So again this bill was signed into law back in 2015.
The board had yet another piece of accountability
at its lap to figure out which was
how to develop a state plan based on very extensive public input.
And that effort was led by Barbara Murchison who has since retired from
the California Department of Education. While the plan
was developed over a multi-meeting process, multi-year
process, it was ultimately approved back in July of 2018.
And I have to tell you from a personal standpoint, we were one of the last
states to be approved for our state plan. And that's because California,
unlike other states, had already built an accountability system
based on a local control funding formula that we were trying to fit into this
federal system. And it took an in-person negotiation with the U.S.
Department of Education with the former executive director, Ken Steph Walters,
the former chief deputy, Glenn Price, myself and
Dave Sapp, who was a legal counsel then, to the board to really
persuade them that there were some things that they weren't
understanding and how California's approach was different. And they were able to give on
some things, but other things we did have to ultimately put in our system.
And so we'll talk through a couple of those instances during our presentation
today as well. So the other
piece of the Every Student Succeeds Act is it did provide
certain metrics that we needed to think about putting in our state plan. It wanted
specifically around academic achievement, wanted to make sure that we
include our graduation rates, which is of course really one of the bases
for having a student level data system at the state level is to show
longitudinally where a student has gone and if a student has left the system
which school and district
is attributed for that student leaving the system potentially not coming back and graduating
on time. It also requires to look at
growth or other indicators, so we'll walk through what that is, as well as progress
in achieving English proficiency, which of course for California has been really a
tenet of ours for decades. And so for us we really
feel very strongly about that indicator and we've I think shown a lot of
progress towards it. And then finally looking at
valid, reliable, comparable statewide indicators, school quality, and
finally the weight. And this is the weighting piece that I know that
President Darling-Hammond was referring to that there's flexibility coming our way
from the U.S. Department of Education around this. And so
what does this look like moving forward? I think there's a lot of opportunities for conversation
as we again continue to develop the
system. So the local control funding formula in
2013 laid out ten priority areas.
And those priority areas we then mapped, actually
WestEd was contracted to do some of the
initial work along with Nancy Brunel from the State Board of Education
at the time to really map out what would be an indicator
that data could be collected at the state level or collected
at the local level. And so this chart, I'm not going to
list them all individually, but you can see at a glance how many of
these pieces are still a local
indicator. They still need to self-report this information. I should
So we have the first three are all local indicators
are all locally collected. They report on them. You're going to hear about this from
Josh Strong in a bit. But when we switch over to state indicators
that's information that is collected at the student, at every student
for every grade. So the state is
dependent on a local educational agency giving us this data
certifying the data is accurate. And then we take the data
and we make sure that the appropriate business rules have been applied and we
report it out on the dashboard. So as an example, academic indicator
we do get that information of course from our testing vendor, from ETS
and we work with our assessments division on making sure that those
data are valid and reliable. And then you can see the other
indicators that have been mapped to each of the LCFF priority areas.
Finally for the remaining ones, there is a combination
for six around for state. We're able to collect suspension rates
but at the local level we depend on
local school districts to determine which is the best local climate survey to
administer to their students and at their school sites.
Finally we will go walk through the indicators
a little bit more in depth in just a bit. But I wanted to make sure I
mentioned the last two indicators, nine and ten, are specific to county offices of
education. So often times you'll hear that we have eight local indicators
we really have ten but they only apply to again our
county offices of education. So those are around coordination of services
for expelled students and the same for our foster youth.
So this is
I think a really critical slide. It keeps coming up as we think about
bringing into the dashboard items like the California Science
Test and other pieces of it that
we need to make sure that we have a balance of indicators
that we have as I mentioned before. An overwhelming majority of them need to be on the
academic achievement side or other academic. So this is how
it is distributed. I don't think you see this chart in our state plan for
ESSA but this is how it's distributed under those labels. So
academic achievement, you see the majority of our pieces are
on the left hand side. On the right hand side those school quality or student
success indicators are considered suspension in our college career indicator.
And I think this is where the conversation that again President Darlene Hammond was
headed towards and I think we will be having future conversations around
what goes in here and if there's things that we can add.
So just to think back, going back to
2013, 2014, 2015, what were the goals
around accountability and thinking what we've been able to do as
a result of the dashboard. There was interest in not only
attention to teaching and learning but also increasing capacity of teachers
and school leaders, increasing capacity of schools and districts
to continuously improve and there was a very
intended process to phase in these policy changes. So in 2013
you didn't see the accountability system getting taken up right away. In 2014
we really didn't pick up speed until 2015 or so on that.
2016 is when the board really started making the bulk of decisions.
And so that was intentional. It was meant to
first make sure that our educators knew what the system
was so they could explain it to their communities and so that
local capacity was really important. And I think looking back over the last
two years and the loss of really key individuals at our
school sites, in our district administration, the amount
of turnover that we see, we're sort of going back to how do we
go back and grow local capacity again. So really this
reset of accountability has added in
an opportunity for us to go back and look at resources that we've
been putting together. We have launched new web pages as of
this past week around the dashboard and you're going to hear more about
our toolkit at your September meeting.
But also one of the goals was to make sure that the
federal accountability requirements, when they were established, that we had a unified
system. And so there is action that you all took back
in March around, and you'll
hear about it I'm sure hopefully later on this summer, for our
Dashboard Alternative School status schools. And so those are one thing that if the
U.S. Department of Education doesn't approve the waiver around that, that
would be a consideration around how do you keep a system intact that is
unified between the federal and state requirements.
And as far as looking at accountability
and how it's defined, still thinking that it is
not just the big A accountability. It's thinking about
being transparent about releasing data. And by releasing data
that we've done through the dashboard, we're allowing for
communities really to be engaged in the dashboard. We have
made sure that through the accountability model that there's also
an extension of capacity building for our county offices of education.
The California Collaborative on Education Excellence, or CCE, was
stood up as a result of LCFF. And I think about like 10 years ago
when they didn't exist, and what did we do back then? And so the shift
in focus as a result of accountability system being set up,
a dashboard being produced, results in districts being identified for
assistance, we are seeing this system of support
has moved absolutely from a punitive measure to how can we help.
And so I like that last bullet a lot because it's
talking about the fact that we're not just here to identify schools. That was the old
model. We're here to see how we can provide supports to increase
equity student outcomes and to be more effective
and be good stewards of the money that the state is investing in
the system. And so
just moving ahead to accountability framework, what we look at is not only
performance, what we've talked about quite a bit. Equity is absolutely a main
goal for the system. We are one of the few states that report out on as
many student groups as we do. We have 13 student groups.
We give credit for improvement. We look at change over time.
We also, as I mentioned, are very transparent. We give out downloadable data
files where I don't think any other state does to the extent that California
does. And then finally that framework was also, we were looking at
a unified system between local, state, and federal needs.
And so I wanted to mention that we are committed to
continuous improvement. There were times in this accountability system where
the data showed that what the board had approved based on prior
year data didn't quite get it right. And so the board definitely
updated indicators as we moved along. And we are committed to that improvement
cycle. And so every March the board receives an update
from the department about what we're looking at for the year. What is the
work plan? And it's really important that we think about it.
I mean, we're even talking about now what the board meeting is for March. So
we're planning six, eight months in advance for work because this work takes
a lot of time to get valued and
technical input from not only our technical experts, but policy
policymakers, educators. And so by the time
something has come to the board, we have tried to vet it through every
means in which we know is available out there.
And so this review does allow for you all not
to make decisions on a whim. It's coming to you as something that is
technically sound, again, that has been vetted. Not everybody may
agree on the ultimate decision, but at least
it's been done in a very transparent manner. And all of that
to say that we put that item back
before you in March because it takes us the rest of the year to make sure
that we can implement those pieces or gear up for a release every December.
And so just to summarize
just the last part of the building of the system as far as just the very high
level, we absolutely depended on and we still depend
on a wide variety of community
members, educators, policy experts, researchers
to have built this system. And just the number
that stands out to me is that by spring of 2017, I came into this
position in summer of 2015. The board had met fifteen times
to talk about this system. So you all used to hear from our division
every single meeting. And while it wasn't as lengthy as this
conversation, perhaps it was on a broad range of topics that were very technical
in nature. And so we just want to make sure that we uplifted that
in the item that was before you today as far as what you saw
in writing ahead of this presentation. And then just to give you
a little teaser before Kim comes up and walks you through the indicators.
This is, I think, just a great summary that we haven't put out
before, but it really tells you at a glance the COVID
impact for 2020, for 2021, and then this restart
of 2022. But you can also see the gradual
moving in of indicators. So we had to move, we never collected
chronic absenteeism data prior to 2017. And
so collecting that data set and then reporting it on the dashboard in 2018
was very significant for us as a state. Looking
at something that we've collected for a decade is suspension
rate. And we can see those checks across the three
years of our dashboard that we've had. That is a consistent metric
along with graduation rates and of course our student assessments as well as local
indicators. So this is just a nice handy chart to
understand what's available out there right now on the dashboard,
what you can look at, and then obviously the pieces that are missing
and knowing a little bit behind why they're missing. So with that, President Darling
Hammond, I thought I would turn it over to you for clarifying questions before we move into state
indicators.
Let me get off of mute. Let me see
if anyone has any clarifying questions. If there aren't any, we'll go right on to
the next section of the briefing. I'm looking
to see if there are any hands going up.
All right. Let's go. I don't see any at the moment, so
let's go right on ahead. Thank you.
All right.
Just switch everything out. Good morning, everyone.
Kimberly Muntank. I am the new Accountability Development and Policy
Analysis Unit Administrator. And so thank you so much,
Cindy, for the great introduction. And today I am going to walk you through
the nitty-gritty details about the dashboard. So I apologize
if you are already very well versed in this information or if you feel
it gets a little bit low in the weeds. The reason we're bringing this to your attention now
is that you have a great reference so that when we bring any other additional
indicators and questions to the board, will you have this wonderful
amazing reference guide to look back on and to remember, oh, I think I
remember Kimberly saying something about that back in July. Well, here it is for you
today. First off, really, how is the dashboard used?
Well, in general, it provides specific information on indicators
to identify strengths, weaknesses, and areas of needing improvement
as Cindy stated before, specifically for things like our system
of support. We also report data for all of our student groups.
So all 13 student groups receive information
on the dashboard. And it is to promote that continuous improvement
for both local education agencies that are eligible for
LCF support as well as state indicator data for determining
which schools are eligible for support under ESSA.
We try our best to release the dashboard every December.
And currently, we're looking at a December release for the 2022 data
as well. The first thing you're going to see
on the dashboard on every single page for schools
and LEAs is information on the student population. So we're looking
at enrollment data for the overall population of the school. And then we specifically
call out the population segments for socioeconomically disadvantaged
students, English learners, and foster youth, those
LCFF student groups that we want to pay attention to specifically.
Then you're going to see information, as Cindy
already shared with you before, on six state indicators
that are gathered from data from LEAs.
The LEAs are reported to the CDE as well as local indicator data
from the local LEAs. So now I'm
going to walk through what those state six indicators are. As Cindy already said,
we have academic performance, high school graduation rate, suspension rate,
chronic absenteeism, college career readiness, and English learner progress.
Now, this is the nitty-gritty. I apologize.
Sincerely, we're going to walk you through
I guess I'm going to say 2016-2017, what we
really walked through the board with, on how we get into what
measurement is for our accountability system.
In May of 2016, the state board approved measuring performance
for state indicators in a revolutionary way, as President Darling Hammond
already shared with us. We looked at combining, not just
or not just looking at status, but combining two equally weighted
components for both status of current year performance
and change, which is the difference between the prior year and the current year.
We categorized status
into five status levels for every single indicator.
Starting at very low, going up to low, medium, we know where that is,
high, and all the way to very high.
Now, in order to determine these five status levels,
we needed to look at where performance
truly ranks and to categorize performance
into what is very low and what is very high.
How we did this is we went about a very specific process.
As I apologize for walking you through this,
it really is important because
you, as a board member, will likely be seeing
the establishment of cut scores and status levels and change levels in future years.
The first thing we do is we look at the results
for all LEAs and charter schools, because under LCFF,
charter schools are LEAs, and we look at all the statewide student level data
that we have for them. Then we order those results from highest
to lowest, and we establish four cut points based
on the percentile distribution within status levels.
We start at very low, and the
reason we do this is because we want to indicate what is
the unacceptable level of performance that would result
specifically through our system of support in intense and focused
support. That's really important. So what we're looking at as on this
list of LEAs, performance distribution, we're looking at a small
percent at the lowest end of the performance distribution, because
we know that these are aggregate levels, so we know when we look at student group
support levels, it's going to actually, performance is going to be distributed
amongst those levels equally.
The next cut point we look at setting is the high status cut point, and this
is used to determine what ESSA labels as an ambitious
long-term goal. So this is the level that we expect all
LEAs and schools to obtain within the state. That's our high level.
So we walk through and set what that expectation should be.
After that, we fill in the remaining levels for low,
medium, and very high, for all of our status levels.
We've talked through five status levels. We also need five change levels,
and those go from decline significantly all the way to increase significantly.
And this is going to look very familiar
because we do the exact same thing with change. We're looking at
setting cut scores across those levels in order to categorize performance
in how schools and LEAs have changed
year over year. Now
we also start in the same place. We look at decline significantly first,
and then we move into increased to check and see where our
goals are for the state.
Now, the reason we talked about all
of these cut points is because each state indicator has
their own unique set of cut points. This is
important because I talked about that we use a percentile distribution
of data that we already have available. Each
of our indicators, the state starts out in a different place with the data that
we had in 2017 when we established these scores.
And the distribution of performance looks very different across
different indicators. For example, performance across
our college career indicator looks markedly different than performance
across our graduation rate indicator. So we want to make sure that
what we were doing with those percentile distributions and this
cut score process was looking at established data
and setting cut scores off of that data and moving forward.
These cut scores will remain until the state
board chooses to update those standards. And per the SSA plan
that is to be reviewed every seven years. And just as a note,
today's consent item for the state board item
of our adendum template, we're looking at a recommendation that
we move forward due to COVID
that reset of cut scores for an additional two years.
So I breeze through status,
I breeze through change, but if you look at the dashboard
you're not going to see these words on it. What you're going to see are a bunch of color dials.
And that's because our dashboard is full of color and that's the ultimate
performance distribution and determination that we make
for accountability.
This is our five by five grid. And on the left side you can
see status walking through
from very low in the current year to very high in the current year at the top row.
And on the left across the top you can see decline significantly
all the way to increase significantly. This
matrix allows us to combine status and change to receive
a color determination. So you can see if you scored high in the current
year and you had increased your performance from the prior year
in a normal dashboard year where we have colors
you would receive a green determination according to this five
by five. Each of the indicators has their own set of
color grids and five by five grids. We did not share them
all with you today. We have a beautiful technical guide that's over two hundred pages
with a lovely index that you can refer to in order to see each
and every one of those five by five grids. But this is also available on our
additional reports. We provide our information there to make
sure the districts are clear around where they are on their five by five
grid and how performance is distributed among student groups,
among schools within an alley in our district, and across
different years. And it really truly allows them to see where they
are and what they need to do in order to approve their color year over year.
In the spirit of
continuous improvement when we released our first five
by five grids we realized that small
student populations were more susceptible to large swings
in change year over year due to
simply math. Therefore a three by five grid
was applied to any population size less than 150
students. So we actually applied this three by five especially for
the graduation rate, suspension rate, chronic absenteeism, and the college
career indicator. So this allows essentially
small schools and small student populations not to get caught up
in the effects of one student changing
their entire rate as is good to happen as a former math
teacher. When you're looking at percentages and it's a small population, that's
what happens. It's just math. So a three by
five looks like this. We just cut off the decline significantly
and increase significantly columns. And so you still have a color grid.
You still have options for different performance. You still have the same
determinations. It's just you aren't prevented from making the wild
swings on either side that may have linked
you into those columns and flip flopped you back and forth.
The additional nitty gritty before
I get to the indicators of the dashboard. These are
the fun rules that really allow us to
treat accountability the way that California needs accountability
to be treated. And in speaking with many states, presenting
different conferences and talking to other partners. A lot of states don't have to deal
with this. They don't have to walk through things and
we have gone to great lengths to really make our system
fair, valid and reliable for all schools, LEAs
and students really. And this is because we listen with an open
ear. We do come frequently to state board meetings where we
have that opportunity for input and really understanding what goes on.
The first rule which takes place universally on our dashboard for the first time this year
surrounds district of residence. Previously it only applied to
our academic indicators. And this allows that students with
disabilities who receive services at another entity
outside of their district will have their results sent back
to their district of residence. That district is responsible for the
educational outcomes for that student and they want to make sure instead of
that student going and their results being coalesced somewhere else
those results are going to get sent back to them and hopefully engage in a
better dialogue around the services they're receiving and the educational outcomes
that are going on. Not just for that student but perhaps
in the programs the districts are choosing. Additionally
charter schools as I mentioned before through LCFF
require us to treat all charter schools as LEAs. So when we speak
about LEAs in any item make sure and note
and keep your tuned in that charter schools are included there.
And then finally our dashboard alternative school status which many of you were
introduced to in March during our item. This
was our system that allows for modified methods of measurement for
indicators to evaluate the success or progress of schools that serve high
risk students. This program whether or not
or however we hear back from the federal government we are really
invested in this program and we hear time
and time again from partners in the field how important it is to recognize
that we have unique schools that serve unique students with unique
needs. And the ability of this program and label
and to allow us to have on the dashboard really helps us show
with these modified methods really what these students are
doing in those schools. So we will continue to update you on the progress of
this system and this program
as we move through our federal waiver request.
And then finally this we have this slide up
because the number one most asked question phone call email
that we receive the accountability department surrounds end size or
population size. And due to wanting to make everything statistically
significant on the dashboard we have rules around
what data we display. And so LE schools and student groups
will receive a performance color which essentially
in our system means that they're held accountable. If they have
two years of data so enough to have a status and a change
and have a population size of 30 or more students
both in the current year and the prior year
and the only exception to that is that at the LEA level the minimum population size
for foster youth and homeless drops to 15 and not 30.
But note charter schools need 30 foster youth or homeless
students because they are a school in that determination
versus an LEA in the LC of that determination. So as you can
see it's kind of confusing but it's the number one thing when people call us and say
why don't I have a color? I don't understand. It's usually because
of a small population size in a prior year that's not
showing up. So
I'm about to walk you through each of our six indicators and I want to
organize them in the same way that Cindy introduced previously
is that the dashboard displays all of our state and local indicators nested
under three categories. Academic performance, academic engagement
and then conditions and climate. So we're going to walk through each of the indicators
as you would see them up here on the dashboard in the same exact order.
And first we're going to start with academic performance.
And our two academic indicators, English language arts literacy
and mathematics.
Now our academic indicators, it's kind of easy to start there
because we remember these. These are part as President Darling Hammond said
of our old accountability system as well. But they look a little different here.
They're based on the Sperner balance summative assessment as well
as performance on the California alternative assessments taken in grades three through
eight and eleven in both
English language arts and mathematics.
Our academic indicators have two components.
One is just the performance on the test for all of the students, an aggregate of
their performance. And secondly and importantly for this year especially
is a participation rate which is our federal law that requires all
schools and LEAs to test at least 95% of all students.
Now as
President Darling Hammond mentioned, previously we had a system that was
dependent solely on academic performance. And
it was also dependent on how many students met a performance
threshold of proficient. If you go to the CASP website
you'll see categories of test performance still
going into the four buckets and still looking at percent proficient
across things. On the dashboard we look at academic
performance in a very different way. And I wanted to
highlight this slide just to familiarize you with it if you're not.
And I appreciate that the distance is in quotation marks there.
We measure things through distance from standard
which marks the distance a student is from.
The lowest standard met or level three
score for that grade. So in this example that you see on your
screen, a student scored 2505
on their grade five exam. The lowest
scale score point range for grade five
is 2528. Therefore they were
negative 23 points away from
that lowest standard. So their aggregate
score would be negative 23. What we do
is we aggregate all of these student level
distance from standards in order to create a large average
at the school level. This is much different than
how many students scored above the bar. We're actually
looking to see how much positive, how much further
your students exceeded that bar and how
far away they are from it on average. And that's what distance from standard is looking
to capture. Additionally, and I point
this out this year because it is the first year we are implementing
a new policy due to our ESSA plan, is that
there is a new federal penalty that has been imposed
that requires us to assign the lowest obtainable scale score
which is the bottom score that a student could possibly receive
to each student in order to bring
a school or student group or LEA up
to the 95% participation rate.
This is a significant penalty as before it was
our penalty was not as harsh or severe. This year
it's different and it will impact the overall performance scores
for student groups, schools and LEAs across our dashboard.
It was scheduled to go into place in 2020
and things obviously didn't work out that year for testing.
So this will be the first year you see that on the dashboard. That's why it's important to
note that it is a combination of both student performance
and a reflection of the participation rate
at each school. The reason that this is incorporated is essentially
that we don't know what each student who didn't
test would have scored. Therefore, we need
to impute a score in order to do that and
the only score we can impute is the lowest possible score
that they could obtain. So it really is an incentive to test all students
at each school and district and we hope that
the participation rates across our schools this year
is reflective of that and that we don't see this penalty really incurring
any problems around the state.
So the simple calculation is just the average distance from standard for all of those
students who took the Smarter Balanced Assessment or the California Alternative Assessment.
And then our denominator is just the number of students who are continuously
enrolled within the academic year. And that's
an important note in that our academic indicator does take
into consideration only students who were present from
census day through testing period without a large break
in their enrollment. So we don't include students who
had just enrolled in school the day before and sat down to take the test.
However, they may be incorporated into the participation rate due to business rules.
Our next big academic
indicator is our English Learner Progress Indicator. And this one
holds a very special place in my heart as a former teacher of English
learners. I'm so excited to see the results for this
indicator on the dashboard each year and seeing really how much we've
progressed in over 20 years since I taught
my students. The English Learner Progress Indicator is based
on how English learners are moving towards proficiency
on their English language proficiency assessment for California
or LPAC scores. And it applies to all English learner
students in grades 1 through 12. And that might sound
a little weird that it's not kindergarten,
but the reason why is it is a progress indicator and we need two years of data
in order to assess progress. So therefore it doesn't kick in
until grade one.
Important to note is that the English Learner Progress Indicator is the only
indicator on the dashboard that's isolated to one single student group.
We do not further delineate this indicator into
any racial groups or any of our program groups
outside of English learner. So for example, you won't see
a breakout for Asian English learners, Hispanic English learners,
White English learners within the LP. It's simply just
English learners as the student group reported out. So those 13
student subgroups do not apply to this indicator.
How we determine a student making progress is
pretty simple. We're looking at the LPAC levels
for, there are four different levels for the LPAC that are scored in.
And we further delineate levels 2 and 3 and we break them apart into
two additional levels. The reason we do this is for accountability purposes
we want to reflect the average five to seven year trajectory
growth for English learners towards proficiency. And therefore
moving from one level to a level above will show
progress and gain you credit within this indicator.
The LP is calculated by
showing the number of students who increased at least one LP level between the
current and prior year. And then additionally the number of students
who maintained the current level four
criterion between the current and the prior year. The reason this
is important is because the determination for reclassification is a local
determination. And so students that need to be
reclassified, perhaps with the criterion being level four
achieving, they may need additional criteria outside of that.
It's not a state indicator to be able to do that, but we don't want to punish students
that have shown that they have made progress to the highest extent possible.
They're in level four, however their district has not reclassified
them due to their criteria within the local determination.
And then the denominator is just all of the students with a current and prior year LPAC
summative assessment level. So we are only looking at current English language
learners who are required to test using the LPAC.
Now I briefly mentioned this before,
but this is another one of those fun little hang ups, is that
it's reflected in that lovely chart that Cindy shared.
LP status is kind of a change measure.
It needs two years. We're looking at progress year over year. So
we need two years of LPAC data in order to produce a
status. And boy gosh are we lucky this year that we do have that.
So that's why LP will be showing up as a status level on our dashboard this year.
But in order to create change, or measure change rather,
we need three full years because we need two status
years in order to do that. And so I'm happy to report
that, fingers crossed, all things looking good
into the next year, you will see LP change
and you will be determining what LP change
cut scores will be looking like and colors will be looking like for the first time
based on the new LPAC test in 2023.
So look forward to that as a board item next fall.
Next we have our very
revolutionary college career indicator. And I know
President Darling-Hammond did some bragging about how California is ahead of the curve.
I can, as of two weeks ago, presenting
and attending the annual student assessment conference,
I can tell you that states are just starting to look into a measurement
of this. So to state that this has been a part of our dashboard and proudly
talk about it with other states, it's a nice thing to do
and to be confident about just the breadth and scope of what we have
in our system and what the state board has helped us achieve.
The CCI is based on students
in the graduation rate. So students must graduate first
and they're placed into three different levels. They're either measured
as prepared, approaching prepared, or not prepared.
And just as a note and precaution, you will not be seeing the CCI
on the dashboard this year. And that is due to
the flexibility in the testing arrangements made last year
for last year's grade 11 students. We talked about this in March at our
item, but essentially because that makes up a large bulk
of the determinations and information criteria necessary
since we did not have all students that had the option
to take our CASP assessment, we will not have a status
this year. We're going to share out information about how students
are doing on each of the components, but it will not be shown as status on the dashboard.
Now, just look at this
lovely list. On the left we have what we established as
experience for our college measures. Those are inclusive of AP exams,
IB exams, college credit courses, E through G completion,
the state sealed by literacy, and smarter ballots assessments.
On the right you see a short list of our career measures, and
stay tuned, more will be added to that list, or rather evaluated
for addition to that list very soon. Currently adopted
we have CTE pathway completion, leadership military science,
pre-apprenticeship, and then for our DAS schools we have state and federal
job programs and transition classroom and work based learning experiences.
On the bottom of the slide we have two links to what I would consider
very beautiful flyers on our website, and we'll be
showing you all of these flyers at our September meeting as we roll out our dashboard toolkit.
But these are very intense measures
and each of the components contribute in different ways and actually
combinations of indicators combine in different ways
to achieve a level of who is
prepared. If you are approaching prepared, perhaps you've met some of the
criteria but on everything, and if you are not prepared for
college or career according to our indicator.
Now the numerator only includes
the number of graduates who are in the prepared level. We report out
on who achieves a level of approaching prepared, but they do not make it
into the calculus of our actual indicator. And then the denominator
simply again the number of students and the denominator of the full
graduation rate. And you must be a graduate in order to qualify
to be prepared for college or career readiness as well.
We move on from those
other academic indicators into academic engagement with chronic
absenteeism and the graduation rate.
Now obviously this is going to be quite
an indicator to look at this year as we gauge the percent
of students who are considered chronically absent, which means
in the state of California that they're absent for 10% or more of the instructional days
that they were enrolled to attend. And this indicator is specific
only to grades K through 8. It does not apply at the high school
level. Now unlike other indicators,
the desired outcome of the chronic absenteeism indicator is actually
low. We want a low chronic absenteeism rate and therefore
very low on this indicator is the best status level, which is a little
bit different than let's say academic performance. We don't want very low academic
performance. So you're going to see the values flip-flop
in status for this indicator.
The calculation for chronic absenteeism
is just the number of students who meet that threshold of being
10% absent for more of the instructional days than they
were enrolled to attend. And then the denominator is all of the students
who were enrolled at an entity for more than 30 days.
We do not include students who were enrolled under 30 days
in our denominator due to flip-flops going around. So
this is though remeasured at schools, LEAs, and the
state level. So you might see different. A student may be
chronically absent in an LEA, but they may not show up and appear as chronically
absent at the school level.
Our other very familiar indicator is a graduation
rate indicator. And I won't spend much time other than flipping through the slides on this, as
it's the percent of high school graduates who receive a traditional diploma in
grade 12. However, in California, we've added
a little bit of spice to this one, as we actually measure a combined graduation
rate, which is a combination of our four- and five-year
graduation rate for comprehensive and DAS high schools.
So it reflects any students who are captured in our traditional
four-year cohort rate, as well as any five-year graduates
from the prior graduating class.
We're looking at all of those students, the traditional cohort
students in the numerator, and then we add in the number
of fifth-year graduates from the prior graduating class. For the denominator,
we use the four-year cohort rate. Denominator is all of the
students in the current cohort. And then we additionally add the number of
fifth-year graduates from the prior graduating class. So this
calculation gets a little confusing as well, but it really is just allowing
us to capture any students who have, through
approval from their school and LEA and district, to move on and
complete their course through a fifth year. And we've gotten a lot of great feedback from our
LEAs and from schools in support of this combination graduation
rate. Additionally, we have a
modified measure for our DAS graduation rate. And this
is a one-year graduation rate that only looks at students who are presently in
grade 12 and how many of those students graduate within
that same year. And
finally, our conditions and climate state indicator, the suspension rate.
This indicator
reflects the percent of students who are suspended for at least
one full aggregate day in any of the grades K
through 12. Similar to chronic
absenteeism, we're looking at a reverse goal of very low
for suspension versus very high for other indicators.
And our suspension rate indicator
is the number of unduplicated students who have an
aggregate suspension of at least one full day. So if they were suspended
for a half day once, they also need to be suspended for a
cumulative half day somewhere else in order to get to count
in the suspension rate indicator. And then our denominator is all students who are enrolled
for at least one day at that entity. The only confusion around this
indicator often pops up is that someone will say, oh, it's one
student bringing down our suspension rate. This is not a count
of the number of suspensions at a school or a district.
That information is available on DataQuest for the total number of suspensions
and students suspended. We're just looking at
how many students suspended and how many total students.
So one student could be suspended 15 times, but if they're the only
students suspended at the school for the year, they only had one suspended student
for the numerator. So that is a clarification around that.
With that, I am going to introduce our
SASD team to walk you through the local indicators.
Good morning.
President Darling Hammond, Vice President Glover Woods, State Superintendent
of Public Instruction Tony Thurman, Chief Deputy Nicely,
members of the State Board of Education, staff, and the public. My name is
William McGee, and I'm the new Director of the Student Achievement and Support Division.
I appreciate the opportunity to be introduced this morning.
Although this is only day three, it does feel like I've been here for a year.
And that's a good thing. The CDE staff that I've met
have been very gracious and nice, and especially
Delana Foreman, Dereese Barfield, Patty Colvin, Justin Errington,
and Rochelle Smoky. They have been very welcoming and very
helpful. Another example of this is the collaborative nature
of the Students Achievement and Support Division, the educational
administrators, Joshua Strong and Carrie Lopes. They were gracious enough
to allow me to introduce myself, and I will turn it over to them.
Carrie Lopes will talk about the local indicators. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Will, and welcome to CDE and welcome to SASD.
So this portion of the presentation is
to give the State Board a short overview of the purpose and
history of the local indicators and results and how they're kind of
reported on the dashboard. The work of the local indicators lies
within LASSO.
So what are the local indicators? State data is
not available for some priority areas identified in LCFF
statute. For these priority areas, the State Board approved
local indicators, which are based on information that an LEA
collects at the local level. The State Board adopted
a self-reflection tool for each local indicator. This tool
supports the annual reporting of progress on the dashboard.
Additionally, the local indicator process serves to inform
planning and progress within the LCAP.
So currently
there are seven local indicators, two only specific to
county offices of education, and Cindy spoke of this briefly
in her presentation. So the local indicators are
priority one, basic conditions of learning. Priority two,
implementation of state academic standards.
Priority three, parental involvement and family engagement.
Priority six, school climate as measured by a
local climate survey only. Priority seven,
access to a broad course of study. And then priorities
nine and ten, which are applicable only to county offices,
which are the coordination of services for expelled youth and
the coordination of services for foster youth. So before we
move on, I just want to quickly touch upon priority one.
So first, priority one ensures that one, teachers
are appropriately assigned and fully credentialed in the subject area that they are
teaching. Two, every student has access to
instructional materials aligned to the state standards. And
three, school facilities are maintained and in good repair.
So in 2020, Education Code Section 52064.5
was revised to require that
local indicators reflect school-level data when
CDE collects or has access to that data. The first local
indicator to be impacted by this change is the teacher assignment portion
of priority one. Based on this change, priority one
is currently undergoing a transformation, particularly
in the area of teacher quality. And AMARD will be addressing the
impact of legislation for the dashboard in its upcoming slides.
So moving on, Josh Strong will present the next few slides
concerning performance standards, ratings, and reporting deadlines.
Thank you. Thank you, Carrie.
Joshua Strong, Administrator of the Local Agency System Support Office.
As Carrie mentioned,
the local indicators cover
a broad range of subjects. And the reason
behind the local indicators is really to get at the heart of
that local data that is specific
to a local educational agency's
students, the families that they work with, the constituents, and the community that
they live in. And so a lot of this data ends up being
really reflective of the community in which
the LEA works.
It's important to note that local indicators, unlike state
indicators, apply only at the LEA level. They don't look at the
school level. However, it's also important to
realize that the local indicators inform
the identification, the eligibility of LEAs for
differentiated assistance in the same way that state indicators do.
It's also important to realize that
with state indicators, the local indicators
change over time. They have flexibility.
And the board has the ability to make changes and
adaptions to those. Case in point,
in March of 2021, the state board adopted
a revised priority three local indicator self-reflection tool
to further enhance the analysis and
reporting of parent involvement and family engagement within LEAs.
Similarly, SB 75
has instigated a
change to priority one that's in the process of
being worked on. And Cindy will speak more to that
in a little bit. And then similar to that, AB 130
section 134 also provided
funding for the department to investigate
the potential for standardized
questions to be included in the surveys that are required
as part of priority six related to school climate.
If there's one thing that we've seen within the last few years,
it's the importance of school climate on the learning environment and on
student achievement. It's been something that a lot of LEAs
have been focusing on in their LCAPs and in their communities
in general. And I think that the
pandemic has really brought this to the forefront. It's important
to note that when we're talking about priority six, we're actually talking
about a number of different things. First,
suspension rates, which are a state indicator, but also expulsion rates
and other local measures which include
local surveys of
safety and school connectedness. So it's
important to realize that LEAs have flexibility to include
other local measures in addition to surveys. It's also
a good thing to remind everybody that all
three of these have to be included and reported in an
LEA's LCAP local control and accountability plan on an
annual basis. And so in light of that, the
board does have flexibility to pursue additional
to pursue some changes to the
school climate to priority six and the local indicator should it desire
to do so. That would include potentially
looking at those more closely at those standardized
survey pieces, which is being headed up
by Lisa Borrego's whole child's division. But then in addition to that,
the board also has flexibility to be able to consider
revisions to the self-reflection tool as well as other potential
ways to highlight school climate
within the accountability system and within the dashboard.
So moving on
to the performance standard component of the local indicators.
The SBE has approved the following
performance standards for each of the local indicators. And there's
three steps. First of all, the LEA is required to annually
measure its progress in meeting the requirements of the LCFF
priority utilizing the SBE adopted self-reflection
tools for each of the local indicators. Second,
the LEA is required to report those results as part of a non-consent
item at the same public meeting of the local governing board or body
of the LEA at which the LCAP is adopted.
And then third, it's required to report the results to the
public through the dashboard. Now, as it
relates specifically to the dashboard, an
LEA that completes all three of these criteria
using the SBE
approved standards receives a rating of
met for that local indicator on the dashboard.
An LEA that does not meet all three of those criteria
in reporting to the dashboard receives a rating of not
met for that local criteria on the dashboard. And an LEA
that does not meet all three of the performance standards
for two consecutive years receives a performance rating
of not met for two or more years.
The rating of not met for two or more years
is part of the consideration when
the LEAs are, when it's being
determined whether or not an LEA is eligible for differentiated
assistance support.
So really briefly, the reporting timeline for
the local indicators. In December through May
of each year, the LEA should be gathering
and analyzing its data. This includes data and input
from educational partners, from teachers, parents, students,
members of the community, other school staff, local bargaining
units, and using that to evaluate the
LEA's implementation of each of the local indicators.
The intent of this data is not only to report
to the dashboard, but also to use this data to inform
the LEA's LCAP and the development and the analysis
of the LEA's plan and whether or not it's making
progress towards that plan. Then at the same
public meeting at which the LEA's LCAP is adopted,
the LEA reports the local indicator results to the governing board or body
of the LEA. And then finally, in late August to December,
the LEA's dashboard coordinator will report
those local indicator results to the dashboard, which
then appear when the dashboard becomes public along with
the state indicators in December.
So with that, I'm going to go ahead and turn it back over to
Cindy Kazanis to discuss educational partner engagement
and annual review.
Thanks, Josh.
So as we started this conversation
about an hour ago, we first talked about how
this whole accountability system, in order to just
literally stand it up, took at least 15 different meetings
from the State Board of Education. And so just to reiterate,
we're coming back full circle. Prior to items coming towards the state board,
the department has a practice of convening
not only practitioners, but educational partners, community
members to serve on policy groups. They're volunteers, I should say.
They don't get paid to do this. And then we have a technical advisory board.
And this is really a national standard that we hear from our peers
in other states that they've set up. Actually, other states depend on
institutes like higher education to do this work for them, to actually
run dashboard calculations. Everything that Kimberly just described in Illinois,
for example, the Illinois Institutes of Higher Education, there's a
contract with them to do the work. So we are very fortunate in California that
the state has invested in the State Education Agency, the California
Department of Education specifically, to serve as your staff
at the board to run calculations, to set
recommendations for cut scores and so on. So your
policy group, though, there is a requirement in federal law to have
what is called a practitioner's advisory group. And so we call that
affectionately CPAC, who meets a couple of times a year.
And prior to anything coming before the board, we take this before CPAC. And there is
a formal input process, just like there is for your
meetings, who they are individuals that you've
selected. And so they are meant to advise you on
the items that we bring before them prior to it coming to you.
So that is the cycle and the rhythm around input from
partners. And then we have taken the lead
from Mao Vang and the assessments division, in which we do a summary
when we do present items of all of the input
that we've received or the webinars that we've conducted. And I have to
tell you, we are now getting calls from other states. So we've talked to
in the last year, New York, over the last couple of years, Kentucky, Tennessee,
and we are on deck to talk to Maryland specifically about our English Learner Progress
Indicator. So it's really exciting that there is a national presence
for California's accountability system and that it's being recognized.
We also are still seeing the
legislature be very active in this space. And so I wanted to call to your attention
a couple of bills. This probably doesn't cover everything, but this covers bills that have
been chaptered and that we are absolutely paying attention to that impact
the dashboard. So while LCFF stood as the fundamental
piece of legislation that defined how the dashboard is created, these bills are starting
to adjust or tinker with pieces of the dashboard.
Specifically, the first two references are they totally
allowed or rather gave the state the
ability to suspend the dashboard, so not to use the data during COVID.
So those are the first two bills. The third bill, I know Josh has referenced
around, which is Senate Bill 75, talks about
the development of objective criteria when the state had valid and reliable
data. And as President Darling-Hammond mentioned, we just got that and we've just
released that within the last two weeks. So we're real excited, very excited to move forward
on that piece. And then finally, if we go back all the way to 2019,
there was a change in EDCO that impacted
how we report out data. And so we look at, for example,
our A-G requirements next to our CTE data.
So you see that now for our college career indicator.
So just to close this out, and then I'll turn it over to President Darling-Hammond
to go through clarifying questions and
public comment. We do have a couple of pending items that you'll hear from us.
We'll be back in September. It'll be a shorter presentation, I hope, but
we have, next we've been asked to talk about
accountability principles that were first really developed back
when we originally put together the accountability system 2015-2016.
So we've put an updated look on it, and
we are seeking input and adoption around those
in future meetings. We will also show you our communications toolkit,
which we're really excited about. We've been talking to some statewide organizations
around what is needed in that toolkit for this year, because as I mentioned,
we have so many new staff, not only at the local level,
but at districts and county offices of education. You will also, similar
to what you did back in March, adopt the criteria for differentiated
assistance for this one year, only using status. And then finally,
we will be bringing forward to you the look of priority one,
specifically where the link will go for the teaching assignment monitoring
outcome data. So to close this out, these are
the look beyond September, really 2023,
2024, and actually into 2025. College
Measures, we have not yet started collecting student level data around
these two pieces, civic engagement or industry certifications,
but they are absolutely something that is on our radar, and we are having
regular discussions with our partners on the program side around
this. The California science test is absolutely on our radar,
as well as the student growth model. And then finally, we've already talked about this
multiple times, establishing this objective criteria
for any state level data that's collected that's relevant to priority one.
So with that, I will turn it to President Darling-Hammond
for clarifying questions and next steps.
Thank you so much. I know it's a lot for
everyone to process, but it is a
complicated and sophisticated system,
more so than many others as we've heard.
I just want to frame as one of the liaisons
that I'm going to ask Member Glover-Woods to also
give us some framing as we wait for public comment
and any clarifying questions, that
the goal of a system, as we think about
where we are and where we might want to go, is to really represent
what we think is important about education. It should
represent our vision, our philosophy for the
ways in which people might understand and make
progress in the education system to support children, to support
educators, to support districts, and
to enable the system to be well-informed.
So just to kind of keep that frame on it, and I'm going to turn to
Vice President Glover-Woods for any other liaison comments
before we see about clarifying questions and public comment.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond, and thank you, Cindy
and team, for just a very thorough and robust
presentation, if you will, but really as it's
listed, a study session on our accountability system. And so just a few
comments before we go into public comment and have our discussion
as a board. I have to say, as a
practitioner in the field and also as a board member, how
excited I am to see an accountability system that really looks
at providing the data needed for decisions to be made at the
local level. As was shared, our system is
built on a few foundational principles, but the two
that I feel are most key is that foundational principle of equity
and also of continuous improvement. And what we've done
is we've moved and navigated away from the name and shame
game. I don't know if any of you remember when all the
names of the schools would come out in the newspaper with the numbers next to them,
and there was just a whole lot of conversation and discussion
that didn't always end up in good results for
students. It ended up in a lot of different places. So we've moved away
from that to a system that I will admit is complex.
It's more than a single number. It is really looking
at all of these different areas that help our school systems
to know how students are doing. An analogy I've used in the
past is it's similar to when you go to the doctor. You don't just step on
the scale and leave, and they just give you that one number to know how healthy you are
and what areas you might need to improve in. There are multiple
things that are looked at, blood pressure, and then if you do blood work, there are all these other numbers
that are utilized to help us know how healthy we
are, areas that we're doing well in, and areas that we need to improve in our system.
Our accountability system has that same lens, and it also
recognizes that it's more than just where we are at the time, which is our
status, but also how things have evolved in student
performance over time, which is the change. So quite excited about that.
The last comment that I will make, and I will stop
talking, I promise, is to just help to underscore
how important in our lens of continuous improvement feedback
is. Our system does not look the same as it did in 2017,
and very intentionally so, as was shared in our presentation.
There are a lot of indicators that have had the data
markers shifted, changed, added,
and that is indeed what we want to have happen, and
a lot of that comes from that feedback from our educational partners, those who are
in the field, those who work on policy, all those who are impacted
on how student performance ends up. So looking quite
forward to our future discussions in September and beyond,
and again, I think this was a great example on how
California has set the tone, and how to look at accountability
for students across our nation.
So thank you very much for allowing me to share my thoughts and ideas, and again, look
forward to our discussion. Thank you. We're going to open
the phone line for public comment, and then I'm going to come back for
any brief clarifying questions. Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on the item can do so by calling the telephone number and using the access
code provided on the slide that is shown now, and so
people can begin to queue up for that. Are there...
I know there's a lot. Are there clarifying questions that anybody would like to ask at this time
before we come back for discussion of
the presentation and our thoughts about next steps?
We're going to have more time for this on the September agenda too, so
just so that you can understand how it will unfold.
Any clarifying questions?
I am not seeing any hands at the moment.
Member Benanka? Yeah, thank you.
First of all, thank you so much for that extremely informative
and comprehensive presentation. In the presentation,
I noticed that for the chronic absenteeism
indicator, it was noted that it was only for
displayed for grades K through 8 and not high schools.
...
if it would be possible to add that indicator for high school
grades in the future. That's getting into
a bigger policy question, but maybe we could just ask now why it's not currently
used for high school.
We actually should have probably put in this graphic, but there's a graphic that we've used in the past
that shows the distribution of those academic indicators and those other
indicators of success by grade level, so there needs to be a balance
under ESSA by grade level for those.
When the board approached the US Department of Education
about the inclusion of chronic absenteeism, the compromise was
we would use high school graduation rate as a proxy
for chronic absenteeism. I want to be very clear. We collect
chronic absenteeism for every single student in the state that's in K-12
education. We report that data out and have reported that data out
on DataQuest since we started collecting this information.
In lieu of that information on the dashboard, it is absolutely
available for every single student group, grade level,
as well as by school, district, and state,
and county comparisons on DataQuest. That's the balance.
If the board wants to entertain this, we'd have to find an appropriate
additional measure for our elementary
schools to balance out those weights.
I think that this is part of the bigger question.
The Department of Education, as I noted, has
flagged that they are willing to think differently about this question
of what indicators, what weights for the indicators, then
was the case in the initial framing of guidance from
the Department of Education. The law would allow much more flexibility
and California asked for many flexibilities. We didn't
get all of them at the time. I think your question is timely
and one that is a longer term question that could be taken up.
Got it. Thank you for the explanation.
Thank you. I don't see any other hands
for clarifying questions, so we're going to move to public comments. I understand
there are some callers in the queue. Yes, we have currently
22 callers in the queue. I will open the phone line now. State
Board of Education, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Eduardo Munoz and I'm
calling with regards to the consequences of the academic indicator
and the LP with regards to
identifying different types of English learners in the LCAT
and I'm calling to urge that together with
the arguments that will be presented by Californians together, that these
LCAT scores are made more
rigorous so that LCAPs
in districts can actually reflect the needs of
English learners and start presenting actions that are identifiable
to support multilingual learners, which currently
based on research, it is
not shown. There is a dire need for our LCAPs to really
reflect the needs of English learners and currently that is not happening.
Addressing the issue of the LCAP scores would actually provide
more conditions to identify that there is a need there.
Thank you, Collie. Your time is up. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Coller, you're alive.
Next
caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond,
Superintendent Thurnman, Vice President Grover Woods, and members of the board.
LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
SSDA would like to thank the board for their guidance and CDE for a thoughtful
discussion of the state's accountability journey. It's clear we've made a great deal of progress.
The involvement and empowerment provided at the local level is shown to be effective
and truly a system of continuous improvement. As we move forward in shaping
our accountability system and fine tuning the dashboard, SSDA would simply
ask that we continue to move forward patiently and deliberately and resist
the urge to add more to the dashboard too quickly. We've had a new LCAP template
nearly every year, so we are constantly adjusting to new state requirements when the
focus must be always on our students first. We don't want to lose quality
because of a lack of capacity. However, by working together, we can continue to
prioritize what is best for our students, our families, our staff,
and our communities. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please
state your name and affiliation. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is
Ali Mazoda, and I'm an equity fellow at Children Now and a student at Northwestern
University. Positive school climate is crucial. Students need to feel
safe on campus and have connections with adults in order to achieve their full potential.
Having a caring relationship with at least one adult at school is proven to be
critical to student well-being, yet only 57% of California's ninth graders
report having such connections. There's a clear issue at hand, yet this data
cannot be linked to specific school sites with the current system. As someone
who has gone through the California education system recently, I know I benefited
from feeling safe on my campuses and having connections to my teachers. Thus,
I hope the board can see the importance of school climate and place more emphasis on student
surveys and the accountability system by first, conducting the surveys
annually, second, having a small subset of standardized questions,
and third, reporting actual results statewide to engage the public on
these issues. Thank you, Dr. Darling-Hammond and board members.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Thank you, Dr. Darling-Hammond and board members.
My name is Noah Bernicki and I'm an Equity Fellow for Children Now and a student
at Georgetown University. I would like to comment today on the English Learner Progress Indicator.
As a former English learner myself, I understand how crucial English proficiency
is to academic success. The research-based expectations for students
who start the lowest level of English to be reclassified within five to seven years, which
relies on them making annual improvement. However, for a district to be classified
as doing well, only 55% of their English learners need to make progress every year.
However, this allows almost half of students to not improve and not be on track
to meet those research-based targets without any red flags being graved.
As a result, thousands of kids in California enter ELD in kindergarten, yet do not reach
proficiency by sixth grade. During this time, they accumulate content gaps in other subjects
that continue to widen until they achieve English mastery. In order to support
English learner students better, the LP standards for districts need to be raised to align
better with research and promote higher outcomes. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Good morning. This is Dr. Hayen Kimner with the California Community Schools Learning
Exchange. Much thanks to the State Board and the CDE staff for that
extraordinary update on a consistent and rigorous process
to continue to measure the things that matter and how to use that information
to support school districts and partners to advance comprehensive
student well-being. CSLX continues to carefully look
at the several important developments in policy and funding that must be
coherent and aligned to support strong, effective, and sustainable
community school systems and strategies. We strongly encourage the
departments, community school partners, and technical assistance providers to center
the comprehensive work of the Dashboard as a core component of planning
and implementation. This includes all of the indicators and priorities, not
just those that might traditionally be seen as the domain of community schools, like
parent and family engagement or school climate. If the Dashboard is meant to
truly be a reflection of a whole child and whole system strategy,
we must also continue to silo the data and who and why
it matters in practice. Thanks so much. Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond
and State Board members. My name is Sarah Arce, and I am an Equity Fellow with Children Now
and a graduate student at UCI. The current college and career indicator appears
to undervalue the role of work-based learning in meeting workplace demands for students.
Currently, 64.2% of students from low socioeconomic backgrounds
do not meet a level of preparedness under the CCI upon high school graduation.
These students are not graduating with the skills and resources necessary
to succeed in their following endeavors. Additionally, 43% of students,
including those of low socioeconomic backgrounds, work their way through college, so it is
imperative that students graduate from high school with both academic and work skills.
First, the board must incentivize districts to value work-based learning
by expanding options to demonstrate career readiness, including internships and job
shadowing opportunities. Second, it would be beneficial to establish an
equity-prepared level of rating on the CCI that would demonstrate that the students are
both college-ready and career-ready. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning,
President Darling-Hammond and other board members.
Liz Guillen with Public Advocates for the LCFS Equity Coalition.
We commend the department for taking the opportunity to refresh the board on
our accountability system. Our colleagues Cindy Kim and Josh did an amazing
job in their overview. The coalition has continuously advocated
that the CCI is a measure of both college and career,
not one or the other, to ensure that our state's goal is for all
students to have equal opportunities to succeed in college and
career readiness. We urge the board to
make clear that the state's goal is for both
post-secondary life preparation and today's economy
that's both college and career, not one or the other. We share
our excitement and thanks with President Darling-Hammond about the work related to
the teaching assignment monitoring data and we encourage
the board and the department to conduct an analysis
of the available teacher assignment data by student group
and include that information on the dashboard and an additional report
such as the school accountability report card.
We want a greater understanding by students, families and the public
about this.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Hi, my name is
Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools.
The pandemic impacted our students and families in many ways and
LEAs know that meeting the academic and social emotional needs of their students is critical.
We agree with CDE staff that if we return to hold LEAs accountable
for student outcomes, it's important to remember how we got here and a study
session accomplishes this goal. The dashboard is the flashlight
of our accountability system, a system rooted in the principle of continuous
improvement that allows LEAs to learn which strategies most likely
lead to student success. The mix of state and local indicators in the
dashboard are the foundation of our accountability system and align to
LCFF priorities and ESSA measures, providing a fuller picture
of student outcomes. The robust level of information helps
drive local conversation to make the necessary changes that best
meet the needs of their students. We stand ready to work with the board and our
colleagues to do the same at the statewide level. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, you are live. Please state your name and affiliation.
Okay, moving on.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, good morning. My name is Patti Chavez.
I'm from Chula Vista, California and I'm representing Parent Institute for Quality Education,
part of the LCFF Equity Coalition and in partnership with
Californians Together. Thank you all for your dedication and such wonderful
presentations. As a family engagement and education nonprofit serving
EL populations across California, we work to empower parents
to engage in their children's education. Part of that engagement
includes having accurate information about the academic standing of their students
to better target, support and advocate for LCAP funding.
LCAPs give our families and us as education advocates
the insight we need to identify where programs and services are needed
and set goals and standards for our districts. Our families tell us
very often because of knowledge and tools, they no longer just have a
dream but can actually create a plan for success and it's working.
We hope you will ensure that the outcomes and needs of EL students and other populations
in need are clearly articulated in our LCAP so we can
work together to provide them with the support they deserve.
Thank you all very much. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. Michelle Holcomb,
Executive Director for the California Association of Science Educators.
On behalf of CASE members and the Science Coalition, we would like to thank President Farley Hammond,
State Superintendent Tony Thurmond and CDE for continued development
of science as an indicator on the dashboard and the State Board of Education
for maintaining strong commitment to including a science indicator.
We know that multiple years of CAS data are required in order to set performance
and growth levels and that this data will not be available until the results
of the 2023 administration in order to determine feasibility of its
inclusion on the dashboard. Yet as districts begin developing their LCAP
plans, they are directed to look to the dashboard for guidance on setting priorities.
With the science indicator absent from the dashboard, many districts are
at risk of further deprioritizing science instruction. An information
only item on the dashboard will send a strong signal to districts to plan for
and invest in science now. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm Todd Collins. I'm a board member
in Palo Alto Unified and I also serve on your practitioner advisory group.
I shared more detailed written comments with you earlier and I hope you'll have a chance to read
them. My main point is that despite its obvious good intentions, our accountability
system and dashboard do not meet the most crucial needs of the local school board
members like me. They don't actually help us improve. Further,
they don't meet the most critical needs of parents, which is to choose the best schools for their children.
I've asked a large number of district leaders, school board members and families
all over the state that they found the dashboard important in guiding their work.
I'm sorry to report to you that a large majority say they do not. Most board members
never look at it. Most district leaders don't attend to it and very few families
make any use of it at all. It's become mostly a compliance tool. I hope you'll
take a chance today to step back and reflect on this and try to meet the most important
needs of school boards and parents. I know we can do better if we try. Thanks for
the opportunity to address you and thanks for your service to California's 6 million students.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Dr. Lina Bakshi, board secretary
for the California Association for Science Educators and executive director
of the nonprofit STEM4Real where we provide science and mathematics
professional learning through a justice-centered lens. I want to echo support for science
as an indicator on the California dashboard. California administrators have
actively advised elementary teachers not to teach science and to focus on
mathematics and ELA since that is what is seen on the California dashboard.
This creates a drastic inequity starting in the elementary years.
It's impossible to catch up. Science is an equity issue with
big differences in access to STEM careers for different groups of students,
particularly our marginalized students. Science could be included sooner
as an information-only item. If it is not measured
or tested, it is unfortunately not taught and best learning is lost.
I truly want to thank Dr. Darling-Hammond and the board
for your time and for this opportunity to speak. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Ruth Brajas with Californians Together.
I'd like to draw your attention today to the low expectations signaled
by the current cut scores for the English Language Proficiency Indicator, LP.
We agree with the rationale for designated six levels of LP
which aligns with the research documenting that it takes five to seven years for ELs
to become proficient in English. We also agree that making one level growth
is realistic for the majority of ELs. However, the current cut scores create
complacency in a system where the majority of ELs have not grown one level every year.
Current cut scores identify districts' status as low in red
when just 35% or less of the ELs grow one level and identify
high status if a little more than half of the ELs grow one level.
Half is not an ambitious long-term goal that the cut scores are intended to be.
In a truly equity-focused system, expectations should be set
based on the outcomes that we want, not the outcomes that have been
inequitable that have been reduced in years past. We ask the board to revise the cut scores for LP.
We can do better. Thank you.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. You have one minute.
Good morning, Dr. Darling-Hammond
and board members. Diana Vu, on behalf of the Association of Kaplaner School
Administrators, acts to appreciate the board and CD's thoughtful consideration of the
state's accountability system as it resumes after a two-year hiatus due to a global
pandemic. This includes item two's detailed
refresher. As the state proceeds with implementing updates and
revisions to the accountability system, such as inclusion of the teacher
assignment data onto the dashboard, ACSA looks forward to the continued collaboration
to ensure the voices of educators who directly interact and
impact California's six million students are reflected in any changes made.
Thank you again to the board and CD for your work on this very important issue.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one
minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, Madam President. This is Brian Revis speaking on behalf
of the Education Trust West. We agree with our partners at the
California Association of Science Educators about the importance
of placing science assessment results on the dashboard.
Science achievement isn't going well, and that's especially true for
students of color, and it's affecting college access because
frequently science is a problem area when it comes to completing A
through G requirements. We need science to be present when
LEAs develop their LCAPs and allocate resources,
so we think placing science assessment results on the dashboard
is an important way to do that, and I also want to say thank you to those
of you who advised the governor and his team on the budget for
the $85 million that was included in the budget for STEM teacher
professional development. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Jenny Snyder,
the current chair of the Successive Curriculum and Instruction Steering Committee, calling
on behalf of the 58th County Superintendents of Schools.
Successive would like to thank the CDE for such a comprehensive
presentation today. Your leadership over the past two years through the
pandemic pause of our accountability system. Thank you.
As county offices, we find the dashboard to be a useful tool in assisting
LEAs in identifying areas of need for improvement. As such, we have
greatly valued the opportunities to engage with the CDE to provide recommendations
so that the data reported to the dashboard provides the most accurate picture
of performance. Newly collected data are going to be incorporated
into the dashboard in coming years. To protect the validity and reliability
of the dashboard, we respectfully request that there be ample opportunities
for LEA recommendations prior to decisions being made as to how
these new data will be reported and calculated for accountability
purposes. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
President Darling-Hammond and board members Shelly Stiegel-Coleman, Californians
Together. Districts are guided by the data from the dashboard to determine
which student populations to address in their LCAP. We request a
review of the definition of the EL population to disaggregate
English learner only from RFEPs for the academic indicator.
Our three-year LCAP reports in the fourth to be available in September
document that very few districts include goals, metrics,
and growth targets for ELs resulting in masking their performance
level on the dashboard. An additional concern for aggregated
score is demonstrated by the current geo region, which includes
current LA Fresno, Ventura and Santa Barbara, and
San Luis Obispo enrolling 34% of the state's ELs.
Only one school district is designated for DA for English
learners, an underrepresentation of districts needing support
for English learners. We welcome an opportunity to engage with the board
and the department to review this indicator. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. You have one minute.
Good morning. My name is
Lucero Chavez with the Parent Institute for Quality Education, DICA,
part of the LCFF Equity Coalition and in partnership with Californians Together.
We are a family engagement and education nonprofit serving more
than 18,000 families annually across California, including English learners.
And today we want to emphasize the importance of disaggregating English
learners and reclassified English learners in the academic indicator.
Aggregating scores masks real outcomes, possibly giving the impression that
students are doing better than they are. At Pique, our mission is to empower
families with knowledge and skills to actively participate in their children's education.
And our parents are ready to support their students, but they need the accurate data
to do so. As an RFEP myself, I also know that students
need to change as they become proficient, and tracking when they do can help us
better understand their journey to proficiency. We ask that you take note on the
importance of differentiating our English learner populations as you make decisions
and create systems to best support our students. And thank you so much
for your service to the state of California. Thank you. Next
caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Luis Manuel Bonrostro, Associate Director of Policy
at Californians Together, and I'm calling to draw your attention
to the consequences that the current cut scores for the LP
might have on our education system, especially given the low expectations
that were previously mentioned.
We want to see more urgency in the system, and we're concerned
that in a state where the majority of ELs did not make growth
from one level to the next, we're not going to be able to see that with the current
cut scores. So with the 2019 data that was released,
we saw that less than 1% of school districts, 20 school
districts to be exact, would be identified as
needing attention to help ELs. This would represent less than 1%
of English learners in the state when we know that the need is so much
larger than that. So we are concerned that the cut scores will continue
to mask the real need by districts and schools.
Thank you, Coller. Your time is up. Thank you.
Next, Coller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. You have one minute.
Good morning,
members of the State Board of Education. My name is Eric Alvarez, Policy
Associate at Californians Together. Along with other recommendations
we've mentioned this morning, I would like to highlight
the board's recommendation to revise the cut scores for LP with a new measure
other than the bell curve. We asked the board
to revise the cut scores for the LP with a new measure
that is based on what an equity-focused system should be producing.
Thank you. Next, Coller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm Martha Hernandez with
Californians Together, and we applaud the work of CDE and staff on this
critical issue. Since the inception of the equity-focused
local control funding formula a decade ago, Californians Together
has been engaged in efforts to ensure that the accountability system
fulfills the promise of equity, parity, and continuous improvement for
English learners. With the intent to make the system better, there are issues
yet to be resolved, including the lack of setting ambitious LP
goals and addressing the obscuring of the actual academic
needs of both English learner only and reclassified fluent English proficient
students, which results in a lack of urgency to meet their
needs in LCAPs, failure to set growth targets and therefore
closed gaps, and failure to provide support to districts to
increase their effectiveness in increasing English learner growth and achievement
through the system of support. We stand ready to assist in
working with your staff on this critical issue. Thank you. Thank you very
much for an outstanding presentation. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your
time starts now.
Good morning
chair and board members. My name is Sally Fox, and I'm representing the California
Association for Bilingual Education. In light of all the
comments you've heard from members of Californians together, we would like to offer these comments
and recommendations. Including a growth model in California
schools accountability systems has been a positive step forward toward
equity and transparency and for our English learner programs
effectiveness. We believe it is wise to examine results regularly
to be sure the data we are using to make decisions are
richly contextualized and appropriate. In fact, this has been a
concern of ours for several years, which is why we continue to recommend the
revision of the definition of ELs for the academic indicator
and that we report ELs and RFEPs separately.
We believe the growth model should include the reporting of current
ELs and RFEPs when constructing the model.
Thank you for the opportunity to share our perspective. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
This is Suzanne Cooey of the Charter Schools Development Center.
We appreciate the excellent work of CDE staff on the dashboard and also
appreciate board members comments to pull out to the bigger picture.
CDSBC urges the board to ensure that information on the dashboard
helps educators assess growth in student performance.
We care about student performance level,
but also it is not only the score that matters, it's how far the school
is taking students and how quickly schools are helping
students progress. And it does matter what challenges those students
bring. That's how we should be looking at school quality. That's what school
quality is about. CDSBC urges the board to take the steps
necessary to identify school quality accurately. This may be
by providing additional information, by conducting outreach as to
appropriate use of the dashboard metrics, by adjusting metrics,
and through sound use of growth data. As an example,
we can see the difficulty with the LP metric, which
does reflect- Thank you, caller. Your time is up.
Thank you, caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. This is Sarah Lillis,
Executive Director of Teach Plus California. We also want to thank you for taking
the time to have this important study session. When California passed LCFS
nearly a decade ago to begin to address these long-standing inequities in our education system,
we recognized a key part of this comprehensive proposal was a more robust
accountability system with multiple meaningful measures of school performance,
a focus on subgroup performance, and a system of support that fosters
continuous improvement. We appreciate all the work that's been done to continue to improve
the measures on our dashboard. As outlined in the letters from both
the LCFS Equity Coalition and the Alliance for Students, we believe that there
are future opportunities to continue to improve this system,
including progress on the teacher data that's already been made but continuing to push
on that, the urgency of really getting to a student growth model,
improving our alternative school measures,
the science assessment, as has been mentioned, the work on the LP, the expectations
for the LP, as has been mentioned by my colleagues, as well as
really focusing on the balance of indicators on the dashboard. Our teachers are eager
to continue this work with you and hope that this is the start of a
new set of conversations, and thank you for your time and attention.
Thank you. That concludes public comment for item number two.
Thank you so much. Lots of interesting
and useful comments from the public. We really appreciate those
who took the time to do that. At this point, I want to open the
floor for conversation. I'll just add
one comment, which is that there were some remarks in the
public comment about the importance of being careful,
taking things slowly enough to know what the impacts would
be, really being deliberate in the
process of considering next steps, and I just wanted to
reinforce that that has been the priority of this board
in creating this dashboard. Each one of those indicators
was evaluated, discussed,
modeled in the data set with data coming back to the
board, and discussed further. Very, very careful
process, and it would be our intention to continue
that process. There was an era in earlier accountability
areas where various kinds of measures were
quickly constructed and thrown into the mix in various
states across the country with unintended
consequences. I think California
Board learned the lesson of being careful, deliberate, and
engaged with the public on the process.
Who would like to make any comments? We can both ask
questions and sort of flag things that we want to be sure to talk about.
Remember, this is going to be on the agenda again in September, so some of what we're doing
is building that agenda today.
Member Escobedo.
Again, I want to commend our staff and also
board members in the past who really helped create this amazing
structure. I know as the superintendent,
we looked at this data very, very carefully
in my previous life. As you well know,
looking at that conversation, that collaboration
around data is so key. I do
know that the window of testing ends in this month.
I just wonder, just looking at a way
to get this data to the hands of our educators
before December, I would hope we can look
at that, knowing that every
district has a different beginning and ending time, but
I do believe that whether we phase in the data
or parts of the data, but I
think having these conversations earlier for school
districts will be very critical, because again,
those conversations, those collaborations that site
principals have among each other, teachers with
teachers and teachers among each other is critical. I do know
districts do download the data and they
create their own dashboard, many of them do, but
nonetheless, I just wonder if we can look at that.
Additionally, the whole issue of
how do we assess climate?
I think we need to think in a very methodical
way how to go beyond suspension rates.
Now that we have a lot of these community
schools being built and
using some type of assessment tool, I think
that is
standardized throughout the state, I think would be very
important for us to incorporate in the future as
we test and learn more. I think we need to have a
more robust way to access how
our learning cultures and
climate, how are they improving at a school site?
Thank you so much. I'm going to suggest that
the staff keep track of any implicit questions
that you want to give us some answers to, but I'm going to take
a couple more comments and we can kind of store up a
sense of what we want to know more about and explore.
Member Rodriguez and then Member
Orozco-Gonzalez and then Member Patio-Bronson and then Member
Lewis. Good morning everyone. Thank you
President Darlene Hammond and thank you staff
for this incredible overview.
I feel like I was looking at my life in reverse.
There was a period
when I ran into President Darlene Hammond in Washington, D.C. at a
teaching and learning conference. This was 2012
and I was in tears ready to leave the teaching profession
and she told me, hang in there. There are
great things coming down the pipe in California.
We just saw how it unfolded.
This presentation that
as a lot of these policies and changes have
happened here in California, starting with the LCFF,
because
it's a shift in mindset and
what I see sometimes at my school site
is that there's still
some of the
scars and the wounds left from NCLB
and when we talk about
being trauma-informed educators, there's still some of that
and that feeling of punishment
still lives in
the psyches of teachers,
paraprofessionals, admin and so this presentation
that we just saw right now and
tapping into the statement that President Darlene Hammond
made about philosophy,
I'd like to think of a way that we can
channel all of this and kind of like
re-represent it to
our admin, our sites through county offices that
this is a complete mind shift. I remember during
NCLB when school departments were pitted against
each other, our schools were pitted against each other
like, look at how well English is doing, oh, look at how math is doing
and so those scars are still there and
I would love to communicate the philosophy
and to show and we're doing it with a lot of the, whether it's
community schools and so
many of the steps that this board has taken to improve
this. I'd also like to echo and thank the callers
for their comments this morning and I want to
echo the comments about school climate from our
caller who just left high school herself,
how important that is and how important the
social emotional learning component, having
students feel connected to the campus,
to their teachers, to their classmates and
this I think is also something that
is directly connected to equity and
perhaps thinking about what we can do at schools to
maybe
rethink what our schools look like so that
we can have real spaces, authentic spaces for those
transformations. Also I don't
want to feel like we don't have the
proper expectations for our English language
learners and I really, this topic has come up a few times and I
want to acknowledge our advocates for English language learners
because being one myself, being from a board of community
and understanding the needs of our English language learners
and how important it is to have a command of the language
to be able to be college and career ready
and I'd really like to explore that question that has come up again
about the cut scores and how our efforts are
being channeled in that area. And lastly
and thank you Superintendent Thurman for
that shout out to teachers teaching summer school. I did it for the first time this
year and as I was teaching about the creation of
the atom bomb and the Manhattan project, I was talking about
the differences in thought between the conflict
between the army under Lieutenant Groves
and Oppenheimer and the scientists
and that clash between the scientific thinking and the
top down thinking and a student of mine said
oh I know science has so many opinions, right? And like all my shackles
went up because no, science doesn't have opinions, right?
There's a difference between facts and opinions and for a lot of the problems
that exist in our society from
climate change to how to create
safer and healthier communities, science is at the core of that
and I appreciate the
amount of money that's been set aside
for STEM education and I'd also like to explore the possibility
of having science, the CAST results
as an information item. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Member Orozco-Gonzalez
is next.
Hello everyone. I wanted to really just thank
the CDE for the outstanding overview of assessments and cut scores.
I truly appreciate the information as a practitioner and how it applies to my
instruction. I work with predominantly English language learners
and I myself am an English language learner and I know how
important it is to have accurate data so that we can drive instruction
and create proper assessments not only to drive
our instruction but to learn from and I'd like to explore
and dive deeper into the aggregated scores and the dashboard in regards to
the results for English language learners. This is I think
an ongoing conversation so I think that for our future meeting this
is something I'd like to also revisit the EL definition
for the academic indicator and the report for ELOs
and for RFEP separately for accountability.
This is something that I think is of
high interest not only to the callers but I think to teachers
across the state that are working with English language learners and how
it could drive our instruction.
Thank you so much. Member Patio Bronson.
Good. Not quite morning, late
morning now. I also want to join in thanks
to the CDE for an incredibly concise
but also really rich history of the present.
It's sort of extraordinary and
really actually it slightly made me nostalgic to hear
the start off with the getting down to facts reports
at the beginning and realizing because it's
so much I think the air that we breathe now in California but also realizing
that it's not really even a full decade old
and that it is still not the norm around the country
to have these types of aims around continuous improvement
of data as a flashlight but also of
all of the meat that goes into
actually shining a light and improving or clarifying
pathways for improvement. I think there were a couple themes
that I just wanted to lift up that some of our
board colleagues just lifted up as well but two that
stand out I think that came up across several public
comments
around a future
in which we're going to want to look I think a little bit more at
disaggregating RFEPs and ELs
and wanting to understand more but also wanting to really look at
what our current data system does by aggregating
those groups and also what are the opportunities for improvement
in the future. I think another issue around the cut scores
for LPs and what sort of
expectations we're broadcasting in the future system I think are
great topics for us to think about in the future and
as I think particularly anything that the department
can share in terms of timelines, spaces for engagement
particularly for members of the Ed community
I think would be really helpful so that people know
what the calendar and the rhythm of business will be for
2023 I think which was named as kind of the time frame when we'd be
looking at some of these issues in the future. And then maybe just
the last thing I'll say is all of the evolution I think that
was described in the presentation
is really the, is a number
of tectonic shifts some of which have originated here at State
Board, some of which have been in the governor's office, the legislature
the many educators who actually lead our schools
and I also just want to flag that I think so many of the
education advocates and equity advocates have
continued to sort of push our thinking and I want to thank all
of the many contributors to this conversation
who are not settling for good enough and I think it's
a hallmark of California striving
that we are continuing to seek to improve this system as we move
forward. Thank you. Member
Lewis and then member Olken.
Thank you President Darling-Hammond and I would also like
to echo my thanks to the staff for the presentation today
even though I'm not too far from the process of having been involved
in all of that and looking at data at the school sites and within the district
it was a great refresher and great reminder of the accountability system and
also thank you not to just only current staff, the past staff
current board members, past board members that had a role in helping
to develop that system and to roll it out so that we can better serve
our students. But without repeating and going into depth on a
lot of things that have already been said by my colleagues I would just also
like to echo my desire for us to look further
into science information only on the dashboard
and what would be a reasonable timing for that in light of
when it actually becomes a indicator, true indicator
with results on our dashboard. Also
with revisiting the definition of ELs
and disaggregating the EL data, what's the feasibility of that
and what information can be drawn from that that would help our
school sites better serve our EL population. And the only
thing I would like to add in addition to that is in reviewing
the memo,
the evaluation memo of August 13, 2019 regarding an update
on the inclusion of English learners in the academic
indicator and others. I wanted, there was information in there
about what the
disaggregation or just reporting
English learners only and leaving out reclassified
English learners, what that would do to the
size of those different groups and how many
districts would be eliminated from getting scores for those
students but also in that memo was about
the fact that
EL and RFP student populations
could have different characteristics because our reclassification
system is so different within districts across the state
and that I know that the LPAC is one
common indicator for reclassification across the state
and then at the time there was the octal that was going to be
piloted in certain districts and I'd like to hear more
about that and where we are with that pilot and what
is the feasibility of creating a system statewide where there's
more than, there's indicators maybe the same within
districts whether that, the pros and the cons of that so that
maybe at the crux of the problem is the, or the concern
is the reclassification and how that differs so much
across districts and how you're actually comparing
apples to apples when that reclassification
is so different. I'm articulating that clearly but if that's an
area that we could look into and get more information
regarding that and I think that
is on my list
that hasn't been repeated so thank you. I don't want to be repetitive
but thank you. I agree with you. It's also helpful to know
where there's reinforcement for interest in certain areas
so thank you so much. Member Olkin and then Member
Glyverwood, should I see your hand go up for a minute? Okay.
Member Olkin. Thank you. Thank you
again to reiterate for this incredible presentation.
Member Lewis just said she's not far removed from
being at the school level or the district level where you're working with this
accountability system and data on a regular basis
and I'm not removed at all and it was still extremely
helpful to me and so I really appreciate
both the thoughtfulness of the presentation and also
the foresight that this would be useful for us
just thinking about how this will help us do a good job
moving forward so thank you. And I
have a couple of thoughts. One, I absolutely wanted to
reinforce or just agree with Member
Rodriguez about the sort of scars of old accountability
systems having worked in education long enough to
feel like accountability was a really long four-letter
word. It didn't
measure the accountability systems. Not only did they not measure
what we cared about but they went about it in a way that
felt very reductive and ableist and
reinforced bad school climate rather than helping
create a good one and I think
one of the things that struck me as really important was very early
in the presentation when we were
talking about the goals of our accountability system and that the
goals of the accountability system are as much about student
performance as increasing capacity of educators
and schools to do good work and
I think that in and of itself is a really big shift
and I think it's a place perhaps to double down
to really think about how the
accountability system is living out that goal. How is it realizing that goal?
How are more educators and
schools becoming better at
what they do because of the multiple measures
in our system? How do they understand them so they feel like they can focus
on them in a good way? How are we using the
communication tools that we've already created?
All of that stuff feels very important to me because without
really focusing on the capacity of
people, teachers, school leaders,
paraprofessionals, special educators, parents,
kids even, to understand
what it is we're
striving for and what the supports are that are out there.
The accountability system will I think continue to feel like a very long
four letter word to people even though it isn't anymore.
And then that sort of brings me to another related
piece about capacity
of educators and
the link between student achievement and teacher
efficacy which is there isn't
and I could be wrong although I did just listen very carefully, anything
in the accountability system related to
staff climate, staff growth,
anything that is
recognizing and prioritizing
that link between
teacher growth, adult learning, and student learning.
I know for example in terms of
developing a strong school
climate, the climate amongst our staff,
first you need to think about how you're developing a strong
for example race, equity, culture amongst your adults so that the
adults then can do the same for, can help guide that for the
students. And so there's something in there for me around staff
culture and staff learning that feels really important
if we're trying to measure what we value.
So those are my thoughts. I hope they make sense. Thank you.
Vice President Clever-Woods.
Thank you. I first of all thank and appreciate
all the public comments we received as well as correspondence and
all of the great comments that we just heard from all of
the board members. My request
is as we go forward that we have opportunity
to also know what has been done
up to this point in some of these areas.
Reason being, not that it doesn't mean that things should not be
changed or adjusted, but it's very helpful, at least I know for me,
it's very helpful to know what has been talked about, what
has been looked at even prior to
all of us coming on the board so that as we move forward
with that lens of continuous improvement, we have opportunity
to know what's come before us so that we can look at
what needs to go ahead. As it was said, really
it's hard to believe it's only been five years that we've been in the system, but a lot
has happened in five years, truth be told. So
there is no doubt that again under that lens of continuous
improvement that there will need to be things looked at maybe even again
two or three times to make sure that we get it right for kids.
So that's my very long way of requesting that as we move forward in our study
session and future items that we have some background
on, perhaps what may have been explored prior to that time
to help us make informed decisions. Thank you.
Thank you. I think that's everyone who wanted to make a comment
at this time, so I'm just going to tie up what I've heard
here and we'll go ahead and
set the agenda for coming meetings around some of the things that are
of interest to the board. I heard the
importance of looking at issues of
school climate in some broader ways, including staff climate.
There are states that do actually measure school
climate in a statewide fashion that also include
surveys and indicators around teachers and educators and
other staff. So there's an interesting area to
explore. We need to know more about what's going on in our own
state. To your point, Vice President Glover-Woods,
we need to understand what came before in various areas.
And also it will be helpful to know what some other states are doing. We are
ahead of many states in many ways, but there are some states that are doing very innovative
things that are moving
beyond where we have yet considered.
The question about science and how it
might find its way into the information system
on the dashboard is one that came up from a number
of people. The number of
folks who mentioned the English Learner
Indicator, I'll just add a little bit of history thinking about what came before,
remind folks that the
indicator in the past under No Child Left Behind did keep
English learners as a separate group from any other reclassified English
learners. In the current system in ESSA, they did allow for
students who'd been English learners to be counted in that group for a few more
years, but then they move out of the group. And the reason that that was
many, many people advocated for that in the ESSA
law was because if you only look at
English learners within the group, you will never see progress because as soon as
students are reclassified, they leave the group.
And therefore, when you look at is the group moving, the group can't move because
of the rules of taking, not counting
the scores of kids who have progressed beyond the
benchmark, whatever it is. So it's a complicated question. There's certainly
a good reason to try to understand how kids are doing at
different points along the trajectory of English learners.
And I think there's a lot of interest in exploring all of those questions.
It is complicated, and member Lewis, I appreciated the fact that you'd
already been looking into the memo from 2019 and some of the
various issues that are associated with the indicators. So we'll
find this about many indicators that there are
lots of technical and
normative and other complexities
to think through. And we clearly want to
put that on the agenda. And then finally, I really
appreciated the point. I think it was member Olken who said
how do we double down on the question of the use of the
indicators, the dashboard, the accountability system such that
it can be understood and enabled to
function as a continuous improvement system so that we can indeed
really move beyond the old test and punish
framework that still creates
PTSD in a lot of educators
and districts across the state that
acknowledging the ways in which several people said the schools
contribute to student growth. That is the main point
of giving people information and looking at for us
at the state board level and for other state policy makers to figure out
how the information we get helps us make the investments that
can help people in the field
make progress. So I think that question
about the use of the indicators and the framing and the philosophy
and the way in which it's implemented are all important.
And something also exploring. With that, I think
we've identified a number of very meaty
topics. This is a long-term process.
I really appreciated all the work that Cindy Kazanis has done over the
years to help us construct the system and her reminder
of the processes that have gone on. So we're beginning
the conversation now and we will resume it in the months to
come. And with that, I think we have earned a break. It's
11.20. Why don't we come back at 11.35?
And you may turn off your video
and your mic, but I encourage you not to leave the meeting.
All right.
Welcome back. Board members, we need to reestablish
the quorum, so Brooks will call the roll.
Member Bonanca? Here.
President Darling-Hammond? Here. Member Escobedo?
Here. Vice President?
Here. Vice President Glover-Woods?
Vice President Glover-Woods?
I see Vice President Glover-Woods and I see her trying to say something.
I see her saying, yeah.
Are we hearing her now? No.
Okay, Vice President Glover-Woods, I will come back to you. Member Lewis?
Here. Member McQuillan?
Here. Member Olken? Here.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez? Here.
Member Petillo-Bronson? Here. Member
Rodriguez? Here. Vice President Glover-Woods?
Here. Victory. We have a full
quorum. Everyone's in attendance. Thank you.
Very good. Item three is the school accountability report
card approval of the template for the 2021-22
school accountability report card. The CDE recommends
that the state board approve the SARC template for the 2021-22
school year and the item will be presented by Cindy Kazanis of the CDE.
Cindy, please begin. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
I am back for item three and again, Cindy Kazanis
with the analysis, measurement, and accountability reporting division.
You already mentioned the recommendation. The board
is being asked to approve the annual template for the
school accountability report card, also known as
the SARC, for the school year that just ended.
Just a brief
background, I will provide a brief background rather on the SARC,
why we do it, why you have the role of approving a template,
and then I will briefly go into the updates
to the tables. This is a much, much, much shorter presentation than what we just
finished, so we should get through this very quickly.
This is actually one of the tenets of accountability. When we think about
accountability in the state of California, this is over
30 years old, passed in 1988 under
Proposition 98. The SARC has been around
for a long time, and there are various
requirements. In fact, I have my staff maintain an entire webpage around the legislation
that impacts SARC, but the one that we
most often mention is the sections that are noted here
under background. The SARC is also considered the
accountability report card under the Every Student Succeeds Act. I know we've talked a lot
about federal legislation and accountability, but the accountability
system in the U.S. Department of Education's eyes is not the dashboard.
The dashboard data is used on the SARC, but the dashboard itself
is not considered our accountability report card. Just also
a quick reference, the department also produces a comparable
requirement for LEAs.
We call that the LARC, and for the state, which is called the STARC,
those templates do not require state Board of Education approval,
but they do reside on the same pages that you would find the SARC
template. So just a brief
piece, because we've talked about LCFF a lot today, we thought it was
important to say that there were efforts following
almost 10 years ago, the passage of LCFF, to align
the metrics of the SARC and the LCFF.
So we have, over the past several years,
tried to align templates and organize sections. You'll also see
the student group information has become more robust to do this.
I also note that this is important, because when we see
reports from other states, there's in fact a data quality campaign does
show me the data, or I can't remember the exact title, but they have an ANNA report
where they look at state report card. We get credit for being
so thorough in the data that we're reporting on the SARC.
The reorganizations that we've done have tried to make the template
as user-friendly as possible. Keep in mind, it is not the dashboard, it does not
have the premise of trying to be
very user-friendly. So the investment that the state has made on
getting data out in an easy-to-read format has been on the dashboard.
But the SARC template has gotten better, and we have invested money in it, and I'm going to talk
about that in another slide or two. I would also
just mention, and I really appreciated that the California PTA
called this out, that there is still interest, it seems like, to align
the SARC with the LCAP, and that has been done in
previous legislative sessions and has not been that successful. There is
a higher vote threshold to get this approved, because it's under Prop 98.
So as far as the technical redesign,
this last year we did implement the full
pieces of what was actually put forward by the
legislature and funded by the legislature to put together a web application
and to find a SARC web design. So
I think we really wanted to point out that you can find the SARC now
translated into multiple languages, including, of course, our
most frequently spoken languages, but it is available now in multiple languages.
And the SARC web application is available to all
schools, although we still see a very low
use of it by schools. Less than 20% of schools are using that
application. Instead, they're continuing their prior practice of
contracting with vendors or doing that functionality themselves,
and then just sending us a link to their SARC, which, of course, is required
under state law that they provide the department a link to their completed
SARCs. So what's new?
Well, specifically, we now are going to have two years of teacher
preparation data, which is very exciting, but in order to
create room, we had to give another table for that second year of data.
So you'll see table six in the prior
year was just the one year of data for teacher preparation and placement.
We've now duplicated that table to add a second year of data.
You will see side-by-side years for tables seven, eight, and
nine. And this information, just to point out if folks are
looking for where to find the teacher preparation table data
that was just released two weeks ago, for the SARC, we do have downloadable
files for every single component the state provides, which is over
80% of the SARC data, and that is, again, available on our SARC web page.
We also, of course, last year we had a long
conversation, and you spent a lot of time because of
COVID and the allowance to districts when they weren't able
to test with the state assessments, there was an option to do the local assessments.
Those tables are no longer needed, since that was a one year
reporting out of that data, and so those tables have been removed from this
year's template. And then finally, around the physical fitness test,
there has been some changes in results of the
administration has changed, and so you will see those results
no longer as the percentage of students meeting the fitness standards, but
rather the percentage of students participating in each of the
fitness gram components, the five components.
And so, again, going back to the item recommendation, we recommend the State
Board of Education approve the SARC template for the 2021-2022
school year.
.